brought forward in 2021, but the actual DMs are from 2020, bro.
They're from 2020. They're from 2020, dude. We're talking nearly
6 years ago at this point. Like Mar around March 2020.
Statute of limitations has expired on these chaser jokes. Okay?
You can no longer pursue them. After 5 years, you have to give
up your claim of Chudlogic being a chaser. 5 years clean. That's
his 5year chip. You got to leave him alone. Okay?
>> So, if you guys don't or weren't following it, okay,
if you guys haven't been following, if you haven't watched any
of the other streams from some of the other commentary people
recently, you might not know. Well, actually, how far back do
I have to go? You guys did watch the lyrics coverage. I'm guessing
you guys watch our lyrics coverage yesterday. He is the former
>> formerly transphobic YouTuber. Okay. He was like openly
transphobic. Like openly virulently transphobic to a ton of people.
Okay. And now look at him. He's he's on the stream. He's wearing
makeup. He got his makeup done. He's talking about cosplaying
the other gender.
>> What was the other guy named who came out in their group?
Oh, Boaxs. Yes. Oh, he was also the guy who a loged the [__]
out of Backs. Who constantly covered the Boax stuff? Who was
constantly about Boaxs? Seems like Chuds are just closeted gay
fem boys. says the guy named Gigachchuds.
Giga Chuds says this, okay, he did this stream in makeup. We
did a lot of coverage of it yesterday and as of today, he ended
up getting in a fight with Chud Logic and it's mostly centered
around this. So, basically, there's this thumbnail. Okay, this
is the thumbnail.
And Lar didn't like this. Okay, Larry was not a fan of this.
and he decided to message Chud and his subreddit was posting
about it. He just didn't like it. Okay, he didn't like this one.
I think there's another There might be another Oh, no. It was
this one. But so he DM' Chud
and they had a little back and forth. Okay. Need a max win. I
need the max win. I need the max win.
Okay. I Let me see here. We've got the thumbnail here and then
I believe Let's
I believe that
Aiden had a story that I'm I'm supposed to cover
14 145 or so >> about three or four minutes of this is
Aiden talking about lyrics, him having a conversation with lyrics
in DMs and how that kind of blew up on him. All right. >> He's
always been passionate about music. I got and I could tell with
the music he was passionate about doing this, but it >> so
he's referring to lyrics was a commentary YouTuber. used to do
all kinds of drama reviews, the whole nine yards. And then he
pivoted into like a music review career. >> The music reviews
he wanted to do. He believed that that would go in segue into
people listening to his music. And I was trying to >> Now,
we all understand that Aiden is going to be transitioning very
soon, but I must I must continue to
demand that you all stop talking about it. Stop pressuring him.
He is in that whole sphere with the like the crazy trans people,
the femazes, the the bunks, okay? He's in that sphere of people.
He will be transitioning soon, but do not pressure him. Do not
make him feel bad. All right?
Just let it happen naturally. You got to let the egg crack on
all on its own. All right? Explain to him that there's not necessarily
going to be a translation there. People like watching you
because you review music is not going to make people like the
music that you play. You know what I mean? So, I I was trying
to explain that. We had a bit of a argument over that. Whatever.
Then one of his mods is being very hostile to me. A mod by the
name of Mocha Pa. Okay, we're beefing back and forth.
>> Then it turn >> You beef him with a lyrics mod
for
>> Turns out Liam is with Kai and Kai is Mocha post. I
was beefing with Kai. Um Oh, wait. That's actually hilarious.
So Kai is Turkey Tom's ex that Lyrics is now dating. Okay, that's
who Kai is. Um Kai is the one who did his makeup. Kai is the
one who's pushing him to be more feminine, express himself. All
right. And apparently Aiden had a whole beef with somebody he
didn't realize was Lyric's girlfriend, but was Lyric's girlfriend
the whole time. I wonder why she had that alt account. I wonder
how long that alt account has been around for. And I wonder if
she, you know, I'm just going to say it, was she using that to
bod lyrics his chat while she was still dating Tom or I wonder.
But we're we're Are Kai Caitlyn the same person? Yes, we're all
cool. Listen, we're cool after that. We were talking. We're friends.
Um,
we had a few convos that were very genuine, right? They were
very genuine. I was just talking to him about like, you know,
just life, right? And and his path and what he was doing. I I
think that although it may seem like a 180 to some, I've said
this before, I think the commentary like edgy persona was the
fake him, I think this is a little bit more genuine, but I also
think he's like having a identity
>> Dude, is this guy always semi voice cracked? Can you
hear this in the background? Am I the only one hearing this?
Aiden, what are you doing? >> This is a little bit more
genuine, but I also think he's like having a ident. >> Do
you hear that?
the dude. It's like he's perpetually in a state of having a cracking
voice. That's crazy.
He like didn't even Nobody even points it out. >> Crisis.
So he meets So he's with Kai again. Um
>> what?
There's no chance that Aiden does this consistently and people
watch.
Get the out of here. Are you serious?
He's had two severe like severe voice cracks in a row. What happened
to don't hate on Aiden? I said don't pressure him to transition
before he's ready. I didn't say don't hate on Aiden. What the
[__] are you talking about? Don't hate on Aiden.
[clears throat] And then I go and straighten your Thank you for
reminding me. I have to
[snorts] Dude, I always forget. Okay. So then I go and I, you
know, uh, I see this stream, not the, not the stream where he
has like the full makeup, but the stream where it's like, his
hair looks lighter. It's like an uncanny valley type [__]
So we dude, I'm sorry. Like the
if you if Lar ended up transitioning, I feel like Aiden is the
prime candidate. He's like bordering on doing voice training
right now. Sorry, Steve. I sold that out of the chat. Okay. He's
like trying to make his voice higher. He's doing a vocal fry.
He's trying to sound like a valley girl. Like he is he's already
in the process. Okay. He's already engaging in social transition.
So, let's just continue to
wait patiently. All right. He's on his way. Part of my friendship
with everyone. You cannot find a friend that I don't banter with.
Okay. Sometimes I go a little bit far with it, but I banter with
everyone. Everyone knows this. Okay. Liam has always bantered.
We bantered back and forth. Okay. He's, you know, he's he's always
been like, "You're gay. You're so gay, bro. You're gay." Like
all the time. And that was still the case like a month ago. I
always joke. Okay. You're gay. You're gay. Gay. Whatever. I'm
not really listening to him. The AI pics of Aiden on Twitter
are up, man. Why did they do that to him? I'm not going to lie.
I do not trust a single person from Chudlogic's community to
be posting those in good faith. If anyone from Chudlogic's community
are posting those, looking at them, retweeting them, liking them,
I'm sorry. You are a chaser until proven otherwise. All right?
You are basically just engaging in what Lyrics's community did
to him and and Sleepy's community did to him and Finer's community
did to him. I see you guys. Okay? You can't do it to Chud, so
you've gone to do it to the younger commentary YouTubers. You
maybe couldn't get Queenman, so you're moved on to Aiden. Okay?
And I don't trust any of you. You're [__] gross.
You're [__]
I'm I'm just going to say it. That's how it is. Oak. Okay. So,
a month ago, even though we were having genuine conversations,
there were still just like casual, you know, [snorts] jokes,
whatever. Now, fast forward to a month later. Uh I'm going to
call into his stream and like just poke a little fun at him.
I think it will be funny. I don't even think he's going to pick
up. He doesn't.
>> So, he I don't think much of it. I move on. He then
says, "Hey, why did you call?" I said was going to make fun of
you with a pointing emoji. Ellen DeGeneres looking ass.
Um, and then he's like, "Aren't uh" And then he types okay in
all lowercase. And >> wait, hold on. >> You with
a pointing emoji, Ellen Degenerous looking ass. >> Okay.
For some reason, I think that's funny. You look like Ellen Degenerous.
Um, and then he's like, "Aren't uh" And then he types okay and
all lowercase and call me skitso, but when I see okay and all
lowercase or k as a response,
I feel like someone is displeased with me. Okay. So, I said gay.
I think
Aiden should be familiar with this. Somebody's annoyed with you
when they say like, "Hey, back." They're annoyed with you. You
could say not pleased, but it's not like they have some deep
like criticism. They're just like, "Oh, you're kind of annoying,
right?" >> I feel like someone is displeased with me. Okay,
so I said gaycoded response as a joke. I wasn't even think like
I just said gaycoded response.
Um, and he's like, "Aren't you actually?" He's like I said, "What
do you mean?" >> Isn't lyrics also? Also, why couldn't
he say that if he was That's a terrible argument, bro. >> Little
bro, he's like like you're know that, but you go around calling
the things gay or making fun of the concept of that? That's just
confusing. I don't know why you do that. Um, >> okay. Lyrics
of all people was sitting there and saying, um, you're kind of
using gay with a negative connotation and I don't think you understand
that that reinforces some negative stereotypes about people.
That that can't be really
like dude that's like this is all lyrics is leaving the left
moment except it's leaving Chud commentary behind. Okay, I am
no longer a a bigot online for money. I'm no longer a joking
bigot, guys. I'm I'm like actually an SJW. I believe in all of
these things.
I It's hard to take seriously when you go from bigot back to
SJW. Okay, I can see going from SJW to bigot. That sort of I
understand how that can happen based on experience. I don't know
how you go the other direction.
Doesn't make sense. I said it's the internet. We call everything
gay. Uh he says, "No, we don't. You're just in a circle of people
who do and use the word interchangeably with bad." Which as someone
who's
I don't know why you would subject yourself to that. It's like
Blair White being a conservative. So bro L is trying to debate
bro Aiden. Aiden does does he not know that's like coming at
Okay. That's like coming at Mike Tyson in his prime. Aiden does
debates about like performative virtue signaling on a constant
basis. He will have a debate about performative virtue signaling
every single
day. And you're going to come at the king of performative virtue
signaling debates and question his bonafides.
Excuse me. You don't know. You don't know who you're stepping
to right now. Aiden's about to drop some knowledge on this idiot.
Okay. He's about to drop some knowledge on this on this on this
gay. Okay, >> just to [laughter] just to be clear, I just
want to How many of you are gay? I just need to know this. I
I have never been homophobic. Okay, my chat has never been genu
legit. Never mind. I'm totally right. He actually got super defensive
instantly. What the First of all, how many of you are gay? How
many of you are gay? I need to know this. It's really important.
I've never been homophobic a day in my life. I've never been
homophobic everly homophobic to me. We're not running some like
It's not some like most of you are in your like late teens, 18,
19 to early 20s. I'd like to think that most of you self-identify
as progressives, but the li the woke li the woke libs are are
not going to take our humor. Okay? They're not going to take
our humor from us. So, we we joke around here. We joke around
here. All right? We joke around here. I don't think anybody legitimately,
with the exception of maybe two that I know of, legitimately
has a problem with anyone who's gay or or, you know, into same
gender relationships. Cuz if that were the case, why the are
you watching me, right? So I don't think that like um
that's like we're that's we're obviously different. We're obvious
not different. We're obviously not like homophobic. But anyways,
um I just responded,
I don't know what circle. And then he compares me to like Blair
White being a conservative. And I said, I don't know what circle
you're talking about. I'm on bad terms like everyone in commentary
except like the former Bread Tube types which is like just Chud
and Queen. I literally uh call it genuine homophobia in my streams
which I have right and I'm obviously a lefty. The calling gay
thing is ironic banter. People understand it's not a genuine
legitimate expression of homophobia and therefore wouldn't be
worthy of genuine condemnation.
Uh [snorts] >> wow. Wow. So true, Aiden. Thank you. And
then he shifts the goalpost and he >> Why did he start
with a guys can I see can I can we get a poll on how many gays
are here? I don't know why he started there instead of just saying
that well on stream. I mean >> I'm just saying like I know
but I'm saying people in your audience feels like there's a general
sentiment there and it rubs off on you too.
>> From the day I came back streaming I literally said
if you're still like a RFC get out of my audience. Like I'm not
catering to a bunch of like 100 layers of irony conservatives.
There are some conservatives that watch me, right? You know,
and honestly,
they they must have like some thick skin, but
like we're not
hold on >> holding holding on. I think that's that's pretty
close. >> I'm not saying you're actually homophobic, but
you probably passively engage in it. You know, I have literally
been and I've been consistent on this out of everyone in the
former commenters. I've been the most woke like out of like the,
you know, Auggie Nick orbiter type, whatever. Like I I have literally
been This has been consistent, right? This has been consistent
since I was like 13, 14 when I when I stopped being a conservative.
>> He got
He got so defensive. I don't know. He's literally right. And
he's getting so defensive for no reason. Um, I'm genuinely principled
on certain beliefs. I like to I like to I like having minorities
in my community and >> Okay, somebody needs to pull that
huge
that huge hook out from the side of the stage and yank Aiden
off and give him a talking to. Okay. Hey,
stop just being defensive. Just call stop. It sounds so
I love blacks, guys. You couldn't possibly accuse me of being
racist. I love blacks. I love blacks and browns. I love all colors,
guys. Don't you know how much I love them?
Okay, I I this just feels weird. Wherever I try not to create
a hostile environment. Nobody here but but I also like to laugh.
Everybody likes to laugh. And unfortunately, there is some funny
that has like dark subject m like
nobody here is like leg that I know of is like legitimately bigoted.
Um, and like he knows this and when I would talk about politics,
liberal politics, he would call me gay for it. So, it's like
he just put on a jacket that I've been wearing for like many,
many
[laughter] Yeah, but the jacket he put on is one that he's never
going to be able to take off. Okay,
listen. I'm just going to say it, okay? If Aiden wants to get
his bonafides back, if he wants to be the guy who's like the
most progressive commentary adjacent person, then he's I'm not
going to say it. I'm not going to say I'm not going to give the
Chud viewers what they want. Okay? I can't do it. I think you
guys can put it together what he have to he'd have to one up
lyrics. Okay? And I will never advocate for him to do that.
I will never I will never do that. I'm going to stop even getting
close to the the topic. Okay? I'm serious. >> He just put
on a jacket and he's now lecturing me on it, which like I was
pretty offended about. It's like it's
why? Like what the [__] is going on? I don't know.
Are are you the one that's ringing my phone? It's on my couch.
Hold on. Okay. All right. I think that's it for the Aiden stuff.
All right.
Weird. Weird.
Weird. Okay.
Okay. I think I've got like one or two other clips, but I think
I'm just gonna leave it and
probably move on to the actual crux of the topic here.
Hold on. Wait, what? Wait, what? Somebody linked me this video.
Ry linked me this video and then was like, "Okay, no, never mind.
Video is not available anymore." What?
Riyle, what the He said, "Watch this video. It was funny." I
don't know what it was. Oh well, I do know what it was. I don't
want to spoil it. That's the unfortunate thing. Okay. It was
a funny meme. We'll just go straight to the subreddit. All right,
so
Lyric's subreddit posted the thumbnail that we're talking about.
Okay, this thumbnail
and they were not happy about it. Liam Donovan music. This is
not the lyrics live subreddit. Okay, this is the Liam Donovan
music subreddit. This man just gets so jealous. It's so sad.
It's Chudlo Chudlogic's channel. Two hours talking about one
unimportant thing is just creepy at this point. He really has
an obsession with some people, including Liam. I urge people
to report the video. Oh, that's pretty up.
Uh, that don't do that. Don't do Don't go don't go to Chinese
community and say you're going to report a
really really really
bad. Okay, that's I'm sorry. That's going to get you blown the
up. I didn't I didn't know how this went so nuclear and now I
can see exactly how it went so nuclear. Okay,
why is this Why is this thread still in existence?
Let's look at some of the comments because uh Liam also posted
in here. Lar posted in this thread, "Stop liking the video and
just stop giving him attention in the first place. He'll only
stay relevant if you keep giving him attention." Well, that's
a good good top comment. Let the guy like makeup. Every man you
see on TV wears makeup. Not that kind of makeup. >> Needed
to see. >> Someone who used to be part of the commentary
community watch. He most likely doesn't care. He doesn't care
that Liam is wearing makeup. He doesn't care that he's a fanboy,
etc. But that doesn't mean I mean I think Larry probably cares
if you call him a fanboy. Doesn't Lar Lar literally said the
reason he never did this before was because he didn't want the
creepy call comments calling him a fanboy.
He doesn't care he's a fanboy, etc. And this guy just comes into
his subreddit and says that yikes. Okay, but that doesn't mean
he they won't make fun of you. It's very common in that community
to not care about something but still want to make fun of it
regardless because they think it's funny. Maybe Chud is coming
more from a personal perspective because he was good acquaintances
with Liam and is one of the people that genuinely think Liam
isn't being authentic with himself, which is honestly ridiculous.
Blah blah blah. Okay, I'll get to the the lyrics comment here.
Give me a
Yeah, I'm not really sure how to go about it. Uh go how to go
about if I want posts like this up because it just gives more
attention to a guy who has admitted and outright said to me that
he lies about me and will continue to lie about me when I talk
to him in DMs. And now it's gotten to a point where the content
is just me changing my appearance and investigating whether I'm
trans or not. Lol. It's like the most pathetic thing ever to
be honest. This guy is 40 years old. Damn. Ted is 40, isn't he?
Chud's like 38, 39, somewhere around there. This guy is 40 years
old. And this and this is what he does for a living. Which is
even more ironic cuz just a few years ago he was called a chaser
cuz he was in the DMs of multiple trans people being lau. Is
that does that make it ironic? Bro, I'm pretty sure a lot of
chasers are self-hating.
I don't think it's ironic at all. One of who one who WAS 17,
BUT OH THE
we got we got some allegations. Now, the funny thing about lyrics
is
he's probably like the last guy online who should really want
to lob allegations at people. I don't know if you guys know anything
about his past. They used to call this guy
All right. This guy
This guy was prolific on Twitter with what he used to like retweet.
Okay. Liam the professional. Oh boy. It's he was he should be
very careful about lobbing these allegations because he's got
a lot of stuff in the closet that could come back and bite him.
And I don't think he's considering it one iota. I don't think
he's considering it at all. I think he's just kind of It's not
good, man. It's not good. It's not good. It's not good.
Okay. It's not good. All right. He calls me a grifter for changing.
Oh, sorry. Do we get Yeah. So, one who was 17 but lied about
their age that they were 18. And yet he calls me a grifter for
changing within the span of being 21 to 22 when he was this drastic
change when he has this drastic change in mind in his mid-30s
going from being with the same trans people he now makes fun
of for content.
Again, I don't understand where the contradiction is. Could you
not make fun of I Listen, I
Are you a total f? Are you Are you totally gay? Are you a gay
man? Because I'm guessing that you're attracted to women while
making fun of women. Liam, do you get it? Like, you can make
fun of something you're attracted to. That would be totally fine.
That would be exactly fine. Tons of misogynistic people on the
internet. Have you ever heard of incelss? They hate women and
are attracted to them. Totally beholden to them.
Ring a bell?
Why would it be any different? Why would it have to be any different
for chasers? That seems kind of obvious to me. We're not We're
not thinking about that at all. I guess it's seriously parody
levels with this guy. So, I don't know. Just going to ignore
it and don't want to give attention to it because this guy is
beyond
shameless.
Obviously, don't flag or report the video. It causes more trouble
than good. There's far more legitimate things to criticize him
over. Like what I said above, it's never good to get into a reporting/flingging
battle. Yeah, I mean, you probably remove the post, though, right?
There's Okay, maybe it's just not on the front page of his
Maybe it was removed and I am unaware. Okay, hold on, hold on,
hold on. Maybe it is. Maybe it is removed and I just got linked
to it. Yeah. Yeah, it looks like it's removed. Okay, well, it's
it looks like it's removed. I didn't see the flag at the top,
but at least they removed it. Okay. It doesn't say remove, though.
That's the weird thing. Okay.
It's not Well, I I literally didn't see it here. Oh, I didn't
click through to the image. That's why. So, it wasn't going to
be purple. I was just looking for the purple link. Oh, it's the
second link. Okay. I thought I clicked through. So, I was just
looking for purple here and I didn't see it. My bad. All right.
We continue.
Okay. Is this the follow-up
reported thing? Oh, yeah. Yeah. Okay. All right. So,
okay.
Basically, Lyrics did reach out to Chudlo Logic. I want to say
a couple weeks ago. Hold on. When When's the time stamp on these?
Yeah, it was like a couple weeks ago. All right.
It was over something else. So, let's let's check it out. It
was over the LA
stuff. Okay.
It was over that. So, Larry reaches out to him.
But what how lyrics represented it in this thread
was basically that Chud totally lied and said, "I'm just going
to keep lying about you cuz you right, that was more or less
what Larry said here." Okay. And Chud was like, "Uh, no. Look
at these DMs. Wanted to forward this to you." This is Lar starting
the conversation. So, it's not like a surprise if you catch wind
of it, but yeah, I've been getting a bunch of posts for a while
about this video and have my thoughts on it. And oh, and have
my thoughts on it. Okay, so it's it's this video with this thumbnail.
I'm very confused. Was trying to watch the new Liam video and
this came up. I don't know if I'm allowed to talk about this
here, but I don't know. I can't really watch it right now. Also,
it's long as hell, but like Okay, whatever. Liam Donovan lyrics
is trying to get past his past. Uh-oh.
Yeah, I've had a number of people ask about this video, unfortunately,
because the thumbnail and title is a blatant lie purposely made
to give my new followers a bad impression. The video is just
reacting to the Rose Malay video all the way back when when that
happened, when she told provable lies that she's admitted to.
and I've talked about it all on stream when it happened. So yeah,
it's made as purposeful bait to great posts like what you're
making right now. I don't know if I should make a big post on
the subreddit just clarifying or address it like this. But yeah,
of course it's annoying when someone knowingly lies about you,
which especially doesn't make sense cuz this guy has been accused
of being a before multiple times for being like 37 talking to
an 18-year-old who ended up being 17 but lied about her age during
co. So given the fact that he knows it's frustrating to deal
with people lying about him in like the craziest, most reputation
destroying way, lol. I don't know why he engages in the same
behavior.
Okay, so that's the post. We're going to keep reading this. That's
October 11th.
Yeah. Okay. October 11th. Got it. I I just figured it wasn't
from today. If it's one month ago, two months ago, doesn't really
matter all that much. Don't think I'm saying anything unreasonable
or even antagonistic by bringing up your allegations. Just a
double standard, but if I'm mistaken, let me know. It was more
of an offline thing, but yeah, not trying to start anything,
just needed to address it to people after multiple times it was
brought up. So, what Lex wants here, what Lar basically thinks
this shouldn't exist, right?
And what he's done instead of going and saying, "Hey, man, uh,
I feel like this isn't true. And while I understand you like
you have your own like editorial standard, I feel like this isn't
true. I feel like it's pretty reliably disproven. So, I think
doing this this thumbnail and title combination is bad. you should
change it. That would be one thing to go with your hat in hand
and just go, "Hey man, I would really like you to change this
if you could do me a favor." But what Lyrics did here is he went
and basically said, "I'm bringing up your allegations. Isn't
that up? Shouldn't we both not do
Do you guys see Do you guys see how that's like not
how you would go at somebody to ask for a favor? You see how
that like might be looked or frowned upon? You might not like
that that much. Hey, uh, I'm gonna start talking about your allegations
if you talk about my stuff. Yeah, it's probably not how you do
it. It's probably not how you get stuff done.
What are you gonna do about this, Chud Logic? Yeah, I think this
is a meme in the channel or on the channel, right? People going
to Chud DK's done something terrible. What are you going to do
about it, Chud? Hey, man.
That was more my editor popping off, but obviously it's my channel.
I don't really have an issue with this. I wouldn't have even
known about it if you hadn't sent it to me. Okay, sure.
All right,
this is like a weird response back. I guess that was my editor
popping off, but it's my channel. Okay, I get it. I understand
what he's saying. I just it feels it's like he could just say
I don't have an issue with it. Wasn't me who wrote it, but I
don't have an issue with it. I guess it's kind of what he's saying.
It's fine. Okay, I hear you. [clears throat] Jesus, I'm getting
close to Aiden territory there. Hold on.
Okay, I hear you. [cough] [clears throat] Of course. know the
whole Jesus. My voice is not going to do well. Just give me a
second. Oh, that didn't help. That didn't help at all.
Okay, I hear you. I of course know the whole DK meme. Dude, I'm
going to lose my voice. [clears throat] Jesus Christ. But if
Noah Samson made a video with the thumbnail entitled, "Chudlogic
is covering up his past." And when you obviously would and then
I think and then you obviously would be mad and call him out
for lying about you. Would you buy the excuse of, "Oh, that wasn't
me. It was my editor." like it wouldn't change anything is all
I'm saying. Like I of course am fine with you criticizing on
me, insulting, etc., but I know you don't think this about me.
Like, and like I'm going to I'm going under my real name now.
And to just have one of the top videos show up as Liam Donovan
hides his past, especially when you know it's just a bait lie.
Kind of [__] up, I guess. Hey, I think this is a
lie. I would appreciate if you could go back and change this.
Um, I know hard feelings over the click baiting at the time,
but I feel like I would appreciate if the title was changed.
Yeah.
I think
uh I think that would be the way to go about it. But instead,
he's just hinting he just keeps he just keeps hinting that like
this is a thing to do and then look, I did it back to you. Isn't
it up? Isn't it [__] up how we do this thing back
and forth to each other?
I mean, what are you looking for here? I guess at least an acknowledgement
of a double standard. Chud says, "What are you looking for here?"
I guess at least an acknowledgement of a double standard. I guess
it just doesn't make sense to me. An understanding, I guess.
Like, do you get what I'm where I'm coming from or disagree?
I don't know. Do you think it's unreasonable to point this out?
Especially considering what you have dealt with.
Again, what are you looking for? He's not answering.
He's literally not answering at all. He's totally
just say you think the title should change. I still don't think
he would do it. Lol. Yeah, but the thing is is if you come if
you come to somebody and you have like a gun, you're like you
pull the gun out, you kind of like sit it on the table and you
like start asking them for a favor. There's like an implication
there, right?
I think that implication is offensive. If you want to go and
ask somebody for a favor, you go hat in hand and you just say,
"Hey man, I'd appreciate this favor." And with Chud specifically,
maybe with other people this works, but with Chud specifically,
you just go be direct about it, right? You just go say, "Hey,
this is my problem. This is what I would like to see happen."
And maybe you got a shot, right? You You don't do that. You got
no shot. You got nothing, dog.
You got You got no chance. Ch would change it. I think Chud might
change the title. You might say like
you could change this to past and I think it's less offensive
slightly to lyrics and still acceptable, right? But anyway, we
can keep reading.
Okay, I guess at least an acknowledgement. Okay, Chud says, "Make
whatever point you want, man. Just funny that you want to turn
your back on your past and act like it never happened. You weren't
joking about, etc. to plate your weirdo teeny bop audience you
have now. Now you want to have some private debate about whether
or not you are making a fair point. I don't care, bro." Right?
It's cuz Lar says, "I just want you to acknowledge that I'm right."
But that's not what he wants. It's It's transparently not what
he wants here. He wants the the title to change. He doesn't if
the title doesn't change and Chud just goes, "Yeah, that seems
pretty up, dude." And then have a good day. Do you think lyrics
would be satisfied with this conversation? I kind of doubt it,
right? It doesn't seem likely that lyrics would go, "Oh, that's
perfect. That's exactly what I was looking for. That's what I
said I was looking for." Just an acknowledgement that it's kind
of [__] up.
No, obviously not. The only other person I've heard mention Teeny
Bob had Chud is on notice.
okay. All right.
Let's see. Not trying to make this aggressive and wasn't playing.
Okay.
Make whatever point you want about me. I can't do the accent.
[__] I can only do the accent for certain things.
I need to work on a British accent.
I DON'T CARE, BRO. [screaming] I DON'T CARE, BRO. Is what he
does. Okay. He's kind of got some sand pepper to him. Is that
Is that fair? Is that real? What are you on about, bro? I feel
like I hear sand pepper there, but maybe only when I do it. Maybe
my Chut and Sam Pepper are the same. I think so. Maybe that's
what it is. And when I say it, there's a little bit of Sam Pepper
in there for me, but maybe not for him.
We'll see. I'll figure it out cuz we're going to watch a Chud
segment. Okay, we're going to watch a Chud segment after this.
Not the same at all. I'll get I I can do other things, but I
It has to be like a clip I enjoy. Okay. And then I can do it.
Okay, Larry's final message. Not trying to make this aggressive
and wasn't planning on getting into all of your other critiques,
but to quickly sum up, I of course find jokes funny, but made
the decision to not be the guy who makes review jokes, especially
publicly, cuz I don't want to be that guy, and overall, as a
person at 20, wanted to change who I am and how I portray myself.
I don't think that's an unreasonable thing to believe. But you
can or not regardless. So, I don't think the argument back here,
if you were going to have this argument lyrics, the argument
would be, you could change whatever you want, just don't do it.
But I'm going to laugh at your past and laugh at you not giving
any positive indications of why you've changed. Right? If you
don't address it, you don't say why you've changed at all. What
changed your mind? I'm going to assume you change your mind because
it's pro it's like monetarily incentivized and that you're just
baiting. Like you're just not even baiting. You're just like
pretending to be right now. Just read Chud stuff in an Indian
accent from now on. Nah. Nah.
Okay. Regardless, I was strictly talking about the thing because
it is the most extreme and blatant lie. If you don't care about
lying, then the com then the combo, I guess, stops here. Oh,
well, here's
here's why Lar said he just said he doesn't care about lying
about me because Chud said, "I don't care was the last thing
he said." And he's like, "Oh, if you don't care about lying,
then I guess the combo stopped here." That's I guess what he's
trying to take away. Oh, I don't care, bro. You're saying you
don't care about lying. I don't know how with this standard you
can ever be upset when other people call you a So, just wanted
to get your reasoning here, but there isn't any at all. That's
all I wanted to bring up. People aren't going to call Chap because
his community will go ape on them. You've gone to a different
place and I don't think lyrics's community will do the same thing
back. Okay. I don't think so.
All right.
[clears throat] So, I guess the big part about this is Chud Logic
stream. All right. Chud leaked those DMs. Those are the big DM
leaks.
I'm going to I'm going to try to refrain from all the uh the
Chaser posting. I know a whole bunch of people spamming links
of all of the trans people as much as they can, but there's just
like a whole bunch of people who are going to compete to make
lyrics or Aiden more feminine, and I'm not sure I want any part
of it. Okay, you guys can do your thing in your part of the internet.
All right,
I I'm just I'm going to chill over here. Okay, I'm just going
to chill over here. Okay, let's go to the Let's go to the stream
itself. This is a Chud stream. He's going to talk about the lyrics
stuff. I'm glad that we're on kick only. That's why I did the
the Candace segment first because if we're on kick only. All
And we're
we're on kick only, then I can watch this stream and not worry
about it. Okay. Cuz I've heard there's some
Want to watch Chud rage out and insult people? Well, here it
is. Here it is.
Okay. I think I think we'll just get into it. Might as well just
get into it. I mean, this is very free today is going to be very
free flowing. This is not like a sort of super thought through
kind of like segment. Obviously had a bit of a think about what
I want to say about this, but
you will be sorry I just burped. You will be watching this twice
if you're going to watch the normal stream tomorrow. Okay, you
will be watching this twice
>> because this is going to be the uncensored version of
>> Wait, did he not stream? I thought he didn't stream
today. Or did he take the stream down because of what he was
saying? H >> is on kick and then I'll do a more censored
coverage for like a segment tomorrow. Okay. So, [snorts]
let's get into this, ladies and gentlemen. Let's get into this.
So, what's happened? Well, obviously, uh, as I'm sure you're
aware,
okay, there has been, uh, you know, some some drama
>> Oh, I guess this was this morning, wasn't it? in which
you know former commentary person Lex
also known as Liam Donovan. Okay,
so Lyric used to be in with the commentary guys
and he used to
be like one of the guys basically now before my time or before
I really got in with the commentary guys. He did have this like
kind of like drama where he was like criticized for engaging
with posts on Twitter, right?
And that caused him some controversy and I think he had >> and
of course I'm I think a Chud fan. It's Freddy Freddy Woods. I
I think I have a thread from him going through some of that drama.
Okay, we'll go through it after
Chud's going to let his uh his community handle that one. I >> leaving
the internet >> or maybe he'll go over. Then he came back
and he covered like the super mega drama and you know he was
on the side of they're lying about super mega but I think because
he had this kind of like controversy around him people didn't
really want to kind of mix with him that much but you know I
kind of appreciated that he was
talking about that and then over time he just became kind of
like one of the commentary guys and I think people kind of like
were willing to um move on from the stuff. I personally always
felt the stuff was like, you know, rough but overblown. I I don't
think it was like, >> you know, career ending necessarily.
Like he was a young lad, you know, he was liking some post of
some, you know, weird youngl looking car anime characters on
stuff and he had some particularly suspicious posts,
right? He had some particularly suspicious posts. Stop being
so generous, guys.
I'm just setting up, okay? God, you guys are desperate for blood.
Don't worry, we'll get there. Okay, we'll get there. >> They
came They came to see a complete aping. Chud, what do you want?
What do you expect? They're not here for nice. >> And also,
the other thing to bear in mind as well is I would not go back
on a take that I've previously given without substantive information
changing.
Like, I've spoken to people and said, "I think the stuff was
overblown." I can't all of a sudden be like, "Yeah, man. Look
at like I've got to be reasonable. I've got to be fair to my
previous takes and consistent with my previous takes. Otherwise,
it's exceptionally dishonest
>> well. Sorry. You don't you don't have to be you just
have to have a real reason for changing. If it was transparent
that your reason for changing was this guy brought up my drama,
so him then that would look dishonest. Yeah, you can totally
go back on your previous takes based on new information. He just
doesn't have any new information >> perspective. So yeah,
I do think it was kind of overblown and and in any case, he ended
up getting kind of accepted more into the fold and he just became
like one of the commentary guys. Like he'd talk about dramas
in kind of edgy ways, provocative ways.
Um he would joke about he had his own version of like the review
and um you know he'd laugh at sort of edgy jokes and all this
kind of stuff, right? Like >> no, he doesn't joke about
rap anymore. >> He's a normal commentary guy, you know,
like normal young lad doing commentary. edgy take, edgy, edgy
lipard is probably the easiest way to describe him. And
all of a sudden, almost overnight, he like switched and he started
doing this music review stuff. And I think commentary viewers
kind of noticed that he'd lost his his taste for doing commentary,
which is fair enough.
And then he switched. And it's fine to switch content and move
in a different direction.
But it was this bizarre kind of like almost overnight switch.
like he totally switched up from being like edgy, willing to
laugh about certain jokes and stuff like that to just being like
woke and soy to put it very simply.
And I think people found it a bit
because it was like all of a sudden he's completely changed who
he is as a person, you know,
and obviously it's something that gets brought up in this so
I might as well just bring it up now. Like I'm not against people
changing and obviously I myself have changed in the six years
that I've been doing this.
You know I did used to knock about with more lefty crowds. You
know yes I did flirt with some [__] back in the day.
and the thing is it's not for me to determine whether that's
honest. It's for you to determine whether that's honest. you
know, I can sit here and plead my case all all I want, but you
know, it's up to you to determine whether you think the change
that you've seen or the you know, the movement that you've seen
in my >> I guess probably the bigger change here would
be
I'm guessing there are takes where he chastised people for attacking
trans people in the past, right? With some of the language that
I he no doubt uses now. Like I'm guessing probably that would
be because he was friends with like demon mama and a bunch of
the other lefties on Twitch, right? So that's probably where
the inconsistency would be way more than the people are like,
"Oh, you you you tried to a bunch of trans people. That's that
shows you're a hypocrite." No, it doesn't. But I'm guessing that
like going along with all of that, it would be hanging out with
those people and probably if he had anything close to the same
opinions, he would have been, you know, chastising people who
were using slurs and a ton of other like that. So I'm guessing
that's where the inconsistency would be. But nobody makes that
point, do they? Cuz they just want to say you're a they're >> My
views on things grifting, honest, whatever you want to say about
them, that's up to you, you know.
But what I would say is
I think that when there is like a sharp
quick
shift in someone's content and then also their personality and
you know the kind of edgginess and so on.
people are going to question that and they're going to think
well why why is he kind of like going like this like not you
know normally you would expect someone to kind of slowly drift
to a different perspective over time
you know and that's how I characterize uh you know my own kind
of journey if you like on the internet
whereas with him it's like he's going this way and then he's
going that way and you're like what the [__] what
what
and then all of a sudden he's completely shifting on on you know
not just like his views but seemingly like his principles as
well you know
like the principle of it's okay to laugh about more or less whatever
you want I'm pretty sure is what he lived by because he would
joke about like that all the time and then all of a sudden he's
getting like super precious about edgy humor and edgy jokes and
you just think well when
is the real person here who is the real person was was edgy commentary
lyrics the real person or is Liam Donovan the music guy the real
person it's like it's like a chameleon changing their colors
So yeah, that's that's kind of like but laying a baseline. And
obviously the other thing to comment on too is that
lyrics
um and Turkey Tom were in some sort of bizarre love triangle
with this woman called Kai.
And I don't know all the ins and outs of it. It's obviously a
bit of a soft spot or topic in the commentary community because
of all the personalities involved.
I mean, are you not going to point out that that's a total double
standard in of itself?
That nobody felt like they could bring that up because it was
totally chilled
that like all that could ever happen. I think that was one of
the things where they probably considered Chad a snake, right?
That whole group, the commentary cabal type people.
Ch I think Chud made references to it at some point. No, I think
with Tom in a call possibly. Am I getting that right? Like, shouldn't
everything be okay? You can't do the everything's okay to laugh
about and then get sensitive about your thing and cut other people
out. >> Um, but like >> hold on. Not that I know
of them cutting people out, but it sure seemed like people were
scared of it, right?
People would seem like people think he asked him about cuts.
>> Like she kind of like flitted between Turkey to and
Lyrics and now apparently she's with lyrics and still is with
lyrics. recently she was on a Liam Donovan stream
yeah it's like that potentially has had an influence too.
So that that's kind of the setting the stage really for kind
of where we are now.
Now more recently in the last couple of days
there's been this kind of fresh thing that's happened where Lyric
appeared on stream
in makeup. >> Wow. Uh, he's going so much. He's so much
more calm than I thought he was going to be. I I got a time stamp
like 15 minutes in. He's so calm. Didn't expect this. I'm assuming
Tom hates this guy. I I don't know if Tom hates him. Tom, to
be honest, just seemed like he kind of was like, "Oh, I'm going
to The thing is about being in these spaces is pretty much everyone
makes mistakes." And it's very hard for streamers to be okay
with owning their mistakes and moving past them, right? Like
it takes a certain kind of person to own the mistake, say that's
where I up, get it correct, and not try to minimize it, and then
be able to move on and not care that people are going to bring
it up in the future. And for also, I don't know if you can do
it with the getting thing. The whole getting thing is just brutal.
And I don't know how you get past that. You know what I'm saying?
Like if people are going to constantly throw that in your face
and I think there was a lot of things adding up like that and
Tom just opted out of all of it. He was just like, "Oh, I don't
like this. I don't like this standard anymore." more and he left,
which to be honest is more respectable than sticking around and
totally grifting the whole time. Like I'm talking about in terms
of streaming and stuff. He was like, "Oh, I don't want to participate
in the streaming thing. I'm out." >> And it wasn't like
a bit of eyeliner. It wasn't like emo mas masculine makeup. It
was like winged eyeliner, blush, and some would argue lipstick
or lip gloss, although that is disputed. Okay, >> let me
throw the chat back up on screen >> So, obviously people
were making comparisons to things like Bo Blacks. >> Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. Wait. Did this just break? [__]
you. Come on, man. Come on. Hold on. >> And there's been
>> Hold on. >> Coverage of it. And people have been
talking about it and so on. You know, you get the gist. >> Oh,
I just I have not shilled at all tonight, guys. Guys, if you
like the content, go ahead, throw a couple subs my way. Add some
time to the stream. We have 30 minutes left. Jesus, I've not
shilled at all. What am I doing with my life?
I should have shilled more. Okay, guys. We've got I think we're
like three subs from another hour on the stream right now. Three
subs. Okay, three subs, guys. Let's go. Can add another hour
to the stream. I'm just going to hit play. We keep going.
So, I obviously covered it
and I made a video about it. Okay. As you would expect me to
do.
Drama's a bit slow at the moment. And this is this is, you know,
an interesting story. I think it's funny to kind of I mean it's
it's Boowaxesque
you know it's Boax Bolexes obviously Boax was a massive drama
sort of calling back to that >> people love the remember
Berry so it's like a nice connection >> private thank you
for the gifted sub let's go >> make and so on so yeah that's
kind of where we are really so I made a video about it okay
and this video ended up getting posted
the lyrics or Liam Donovan music subreddit. Okay, and let's have
a quick look at that. >> Take a look at the video. >> This
man just gets so jealous. It's so
Two hours talking about one unimportant thing is just creepy
at this point.
>> Very weird. >> He really has >> disgusting
creepy behavior. So true. >> Obsession with some people,
including Liam. I urge people to report the video. I mean,
yeah, I actually know Liam, right? We used to knock about together.
So obviously him putting makeup on on a stream is such a big
shift from his previous behavior that yeah, I've got some level
of personal interest in it. But what's really frustrating about
this take is this obsession idea. I have been more than reasonable
with this, bro. this wretch.
what [laughter] what the I disavowed that that comment
to an to an absolute extent. What the
>> dude? It really does just come out of nowhere, doesn't
it? As calm, calm, cal com 100.
>> Jesus Christ.
>> But what's really frustrating about this take is this
obsession idea. I have been more than reasonable with this, bro.
This wretched pathetic dude. I have been more than reasonable
with this guy. And now his fans are calling me obsessed, bro.
I could have cut 20 videos about this loser over the past 6 months
if I wanted to. Okay. But I didn't because do you know what?
Do you know the honest truth is, right? >> I don't care.
He's a loser. I don't give a as much as I've covered him here
and there. I didn't want to, you know, his
Oh, actually, totally different. Oh, I didn't expect that.
[laughter] Uh oh. I actually didn't want to [__]
with his new program. I I like laughed at it, but I didn't want
to [__] with his new channel. You know, new creator
going to make his way in a different way. Okay, God bless.
Uh-oh. Larry was Larry was getting protected.
I you know I think this is almost certainly true cuz when you
think about it I know Quean whenever Quimman sees something he
doesn't like he shoots Ch a message he says you should cover
this okay like Queen does like doing that okay he just likes
going this is [__] stupid this guy's a total hypocrite
and Chud probably was like ah who cares who cares
and
now
Lar and L's community have totally up the protection that they
had. >> I didn't want him to be in a position where he's
getting totally
because of his past. And if he wants to move on and do his thing,
then fair enough. It's so ridiculous, bro, that people are acting
like I'm obsessed with Liam when I could have cut a bunch of
videos about this loser, but I didn't because I I'm going to
be honest.
Esser feels pretty uh performative here. I don't think it was
necessary. I don't think he really is really feeling it that
much. I I don't I actually don't. In his heart of hearts, I think
in his heart of hearts,
that's not who Trud is. I don't think so, but who knows? I really
don't know him that well. >> Genuinely was like, if he's
moving on, good luck to him. Okay. And also, I'm pretty sure
at points I've said on
>> although I will say he's been on YouTube a long time,
it's possible it's just like a learned behavior not to go to
where he naturally feels he should go. And that that's what I
was picking up.
How many views did Chud did the Chud video on him get? It's Is
this one of the scenarios where Ler's crying in DMs is going
to make it more embarrassing and bad for him? Oh, for sure. This
one I mean this one was big. The one where he cried in DMs was
from before and I don't know if that one did very well. Let's
uh let's check that out real quick. Hold on. Let's check this
out. Let's just see
Uh so we've got this one. 11K views one day ago, but there's
um lyrics past. Let's see if we can find it here. What was it
called? Let me go to the Twitter again. Tweets. The tweets. Oh,
hold on. Let me see what what this video was called. Oh, it's
on Chud Noir. I see. Is it Chudlogic Noir? Is it Chud Noir? I'll
Oh, nice. Nailed it.
So, Lyrics
past.
Okay. 28,000 views. So, actually pretty big video to be honest
for Chud's channel. For Ch's second channel, it's got to be pretty
massive. No. 28,000 views is pretty huge, dude. 28. That got
[laughter] a lot of views. I think that's quite big for one of
Chud's
It's H. It's not in the top 10.
I thought for for second channel. I thought for sure that was
going to be like top 10. You have to go down quite a bit to actually
find it. So, did I scroll past it? Yeah, there it is. You have
to go down quite a bit, but it's still, you know, top 15, top
16 videos. So yeah, I think probably no matter what, the crying
about it is going to be worse. Okay, there's almost no way the
crying about it is going to make it better. It can't can't be
done. >> I'm pretty sure I've said at points on stream
that I'm Good for him. Good for him. Sorry, one sec. Sorry. So,
it's ex exceptionally irritating
that is fan base are acting like I'm obsessed. And even this,
I probably would have talked about it in passing as a funny thing
that happened. Okay.
And I probably would have shown stuff like this
because it's funny. Because it's funny.
Where is it? This here.
>> Don't Don't do it. >> Watch it to see what evidence
he had of Liam being trans, but he spent the entire time calling
him the Arsler and saying he was queer. [laughter] Genuinely
a disgusting individual with an equally as bad fan base. [laughter]
Problem. Problem. Oh, he watches a lot of Queenman, too. I noticed
um
>> Ralph started doing this after watching Queen for a
little bit as well. >> There's a there's a queenism. I
don't know who else did it first. I don't know if anyone did
it first. I just I think problem is a queenism. Okay, 100%.
>> So, I thought that was quite funny.
Anyway, this is the kind of thing that I would have done with
this, okay,
had it been the case that this is all that happened. Whatever.
It's a funny thing or whatever, right?
But for some reason, Liam has seen fit to respond. Now, I don't
mind if Liam wants to respond to this. Okay. And you will see
I have been exceptionally gracious
about Liam.
>> Nah. Nah, it's not the old trollface thing. It's like
a It's like a trollface thing kind of, but I'm sorry. He's the
only one uh he's the only one I've ever heard do it.
Do it effectively. >> Respond. Now, I don't mind if Liam
wants to respond to this, okay? And you will see I have been
exceptionally gracious
about Liam responding to his community about things. You will
see in a moment, okay? But the thing is, he crossed the line
from just talking to his community about whatever the he wants
to talk about to totally smearing me for no reason. Bro, I get
talking [__] about me. I get having a bit of a whatever,
but lying about me, absolutely not, dude. Absolutely [__]
not. I don't care, okay, if this queer thinks he's managed to
escape from the commentary community, okay? Don't lie about me,
you loser, because I will correct the record, dude. Every time
if you try and misrepresent me. Holy [__] dude. It's
so irritating, bro. Go and do your Why are you even responding
to this? Just delete it from your subreddit if you got that much
of a problem with it. Why? >> Has shut even talked about
the fact that they talked about reporting him yet or
maybe I checked I checked my uh sorry [clears throat] I checked
a Discord message really quickly there in the middle of that.
I thought I got all of it.
Has he even gotten to the point where he's going to rage out
about the reporting? Cuz the reporting has got to be the most
egregious part. If you guys don't remember, I believe this is
what he perma banned multiple people from his Discord for.
Okay. Like I think this is the thing from what I recall this
is the thing that upsets him the most. Like if you come for his
channel if you come for his income like you it's on like you're
you're going to get up >> lie about me dude >> when
I've got the evidence to prove that you're lying dude. So stupid.
Anyway, this was his post. So this is what he posted.
Okay. Yeah. I'm not really sure how to go about if I want posts
like this up because it just gives more attention to a guy who
has admitted and outright said to me that he lies about me and
will continue to lie about me when I talk to him in DMs. Now,
let me ask you this, guys. Okay, I've been doing this a long
time. I've been doing this six years. Okay.
Now, first of all, do you think that I'm someone that is comfortable
with just lying about someone flatly? Do you think that's me,
first of all? And secondly,
okay. [clears throat]
but uh No.
But there's a shell game that gets played with DK and I understand
it and it's fine.
But you he has to understand the shell game that gets played
and what people think about that, right? He has to understand
it. There's no way he cannot understand it. He absolutely has
to get it that Larry is mad at DK and Larry expects you to do
something.
I'm I like realistically if if the thumbnail and title of your
video is not representative of your opinion, then you are doing
something dishonest. You can call that a lie. You could be pedantic
about it, but that's true, right? That's that's just true. And
I I would agree based on his opinion. He stated that it's pretty
obvious that he doesn't agree with that thumbnail or sorry the
title. Oh, but the title's updated. Oh, wait. This is the wrong
video. Me. Sorry. It was the Chloic Noir video that I was looking
for. This one. Oh, yeah. No, then he doesn't agree with this.
He doesn't agree. Trying to hide his past,
right? Like I don't I don't know if Chud thinks h Chud might
think but it didn't seem like he really thought that this guy
had a past and that it was sort of overblown. Feel like DK gets
Chud into trouble. I just think you can't as Chud you probably
can't be that mad. If you want to use the DK shield if you want
to say well DK does what DK does then I think you can't be mad
when somebody calls you a liar about so much. I think the thing
that really strikes me as incorrect about how the way lyrics
frame this is he says Chud lied to me in DMs.
Right. I don't think Chud lied to him in DMs. I think Chud laid
it out pretty clearly in DMs like what he thinks and like [__]
off.
But I do understand how the the shell game is frustrating or
could be frustrating for lyrics,
right? What's the excuse for teens on Omegle? I'm unaware of
this part of the drama. If that's there,
if that's if that's a thing that happened, I'm unaware of that.
I guess we'll look into it or we'll look into it. I'm guessing
we'll see it as we go through this. Even if you thought that
was true, do you think I would say to someone in DMs,
I have lied about you and will continue to lie about you?
I mean, just from a pragmatic perspective,
>> just from a [__] >> So, so that's
that's the part where I think Larry was really stretching it,
right? Where he's like, "Oh, well, I guess if you're just going
to say you lie about me, the conversation ends here." And then
he takes that away as Chuda has said he will remain lying. He
will continue to lie about me because he didn't respond to me
and that's kind of [__] pragmatic perspective. Why
the would I admit to that in DMs? What an insane mission that
would just get used against you if you thought it was funny.
Yes. Okay. Well, anyway, I wasn't quite getting the reaction
that I hoped. Okay. But you know what I'm trying to get at, right?
Like I know there's a bit of a meme about it, but like I I'm
not in the business of just making [__] up about
people whole cloth. Okay. I'm not going to just make some crazy
[__] up. There might be some provocative presentation
which will come up or something like that but there's always
like a kernel of truth in it and I'm never just going to completely
push complete bogus fabricated about people and that is what
he is suggesting is happening which and not only that but I'm
admitting to that too. So obviously completely outrageous
claims that this loser is making to me.
>> Ch doesn't lie but he definitely does twist the truth
for a laugh which would be lying. I think he'll lean into
hyperbole in a way that he doesn't even agree with. Wouldn't
be like his legitimate take, but I do think a lot of people do
that and it's like, okay, you can criticize it,
but then if you ask him, he'd pull it back. I don't know. I can't
think of a time where he's gone out of his way to straight up
say like, I'm going to lie about this. You're going to nitpick
lyrics is the clear winner. The winner. I mean,
is he? I need to I guess I need to see all the evidence on lyrics.
Okay. If it's just a
then it's
that would be up in the air I guess. I don't know.
But also like it depends on what you mean by you mean like strict
dictionary definition then probably not because there's no allegations
the child has ever done that. You want to just say under 18 then
uh then maybe you could argue it I guess >> you know very
irritating
very
Continuing on.
And now it's gone to a point where the content is just me changing
my appearance and investigating whether I'm trans or not. Lol.
Okay. I mean, changing your appearance is like slapping a bunch
of make makeup on in a disconcerting fashion, but nonetheless,
we don't need to dwell on that. It's the most pathetic thing
ever, to be honest. This guy is 40 years old and this is what
he does for a living. Which is even more ironic because just
a few years ago he was called a chaser
because he was in the DMs of multiple trans people being them
out. One of who was 17 but lied about their age they were 18.
So there's a few there's a few things there to talk about. Okay.
>> Is he wait is he
is he going to disagree with that? I thought that was uh I mean
I guess sorry as far as the allegations go I think that's probably
fairly accurate right
there's a few things there to talk about people saying he's No
he hasn't he hasn't what you on about dude what are you on about
listen yes we all get it okay yes I flirted with some [__]
a few years ago do you want to know how long ago that was by
the way do you want to know how long ago that was
>> four years ago >> it was brought forward in 2021
on. But the actual DMs are from 2020, bro. They're from 2020.
They're from 2020, dude. We're talking nearly 6 years ago at
this point. Like Mar around March
>> It's like the statute of limitations has expired on
these chaser jokes. Okay? You can no longer pursue them after
5 years. You have to give up your claim of Chud Logic being a
chaser. Five years clean. That's his fiveyear chip. You got to
leave him alone. Okay? That's the argument. I guess that's the
argument we're getting >> so long ago at this point and
I get it. People like to bring it up because it's like an easy
little attack against me or whatever. Okay.
Right. But it's like, bro, we're talking about nearly coming
up on six years ago that this happened, dude. And we're talking
about Liam's behavior last year or, you know, a year a year and
a half a year and a half ago, say. Right. Okay.
And the thing that's really like, look, I get it, right? The
40-year-old thing, whatever. Okay? Um, if you want to [__]
go at me for my age, so be it. But what's so funny about that,
right? I'm 39.
Okay? I'm 39.
When when I was 37 and 38, this wretch was hanging ABOUT WITH
ME. HE WAS TALKING to me privately. He was hopping on Discord
calls with me to talk about drama. So, hang on a minute, mate.
So all of a sudden my age is some big issue.
Okay. But like literally when I was 37 38 you were hanging about
with me.
It's like so obnoxious and dishonest. This guy's such a wretched
pathetic liar. Man, >> this is why you should always remind
Chud that he's old, that death is at his door, that he is decrepit
and will be done away with soon. Because if you don't do that,
if you don't do that repeatedly, he will accuse you. Sorry. He
will accuse you of being disingenuous later. Okay? You constantly
need to mock him for this or he will say that you're disingenuous.
You are inconsistent. All right. Very sad. Acting like my age
is a problem when it's obviously not because when I was 37 and
38, we were literally in calls together talking about drama.
He was reacting to my content. He was talking about my content.
He was doing coverage of stuff that I was involved in. And
>> Always remind Chud that he had an old man fall. Chud
Chud's got one of those Life Alert BLA bracelets. Okay. He hits
the button. >> I fallen and I can't get up. [laughter]
>> Talking about and vice versa, too. And it never came
up.
>> Never came up once. Only now. Right. Only now that there's
videos that are coming out that I'm criticizing or whatever.
All of a sudden now my age is some big problem. >> Logic.
You will never escape that you had gay thoughts six years ago.
>> Thank you for the kicks.
Oh, I need to enable my kick TTS. What the? How does he have
kick TTS?
I think he uses the same thing. >> So, it's obviously just
so dishonest. It's such that my age is an issue because it never
was before when we were friendly. We were hopping on calls together
when we were, you know, talking about dramas and bouncing off
each other and stuff like that, right? Why didn't why has it
not come up before lyrics? You know, I'm not sat here all of
a sudden changing my tune on the stuff, right? Because I've actually
got some principles and it would be exceptionally dishonest for
me to have previously when we were on better terms, you know,
I've defended you on that because I genuinely believe that was
the right take to all of a sudden change it now. It's such a
dishonest thing to do. Lex clearly has got no qualms with that
though and he's acting like all of a sudden
my age is some issue when we were literally >> oh Chard
he's crying >> knocking about together when I was 37 38
it's outrageous dude it's totally outrageous you know if someone
from the start is like old man >> I mean realistically
the age thing doesn't matter
right if the guy's funny the guy's funny Mike David's got to
be Way older than Chud, right? How old is Mike David? Mike David
age. Red Bar's got to be old as No.
Got to be, bro. No way. No way. This is the Mike D. This is a
different Mike David, isn't it? The NASCAR racer. Nope. Red Bar.
Red Bar's 40th birthday was 2019. He is 45. He's way older, bro.
It's just about the product. Okay, that's realistically all it
is. And you're covering drama loser. Then yeah, you've got a
consistent perspective there. Fair enough. whatever. But this
guy is full of it. He's not got a problem with my age. And he's
just saying this to appeal to his teenage audience.
He's trying to handwave me away as some old weirdo that's talking
about this. [clears throat] Bro, we were joking about together
just two years ago, dude.
>> Now, does that apply to Quean as well? I I believe Queean
constantly points out how old Chud is, right? Does that apply
to Quean, too? Queen ever like, you know, burns the bridge, walks
away, can he call Chud old because he did it before, but then
realistically he hung out with Chud. So, was he cool with Chud
being old or was he actually not cool because he said it? Or
was that just banter? I actually don't know. I don't >> And
yet he calls me a grifter
for changing within the span of being 21 to >> You can't
call me old. We joked about
We joked about together. You didn't even call me a decrepit old.
How could you do it now? It's so It's so wrong. >> 22 when
he has this drastic change in his mid30s going from being with
the same trans people he now makes fun of for content. Here's
the thing, right? I could be Oh, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold
on. Oh, he got too far into it. I was just going to predict it.
He's going to say what I said.
He could be chasing. He could have eight trans women in his DMs
messaging him right now and he could be with all of them and
he could still make fun of trans people on stream and that would
be fine. There's no hypocrisy there. You >> flirting
with a right now in DMs, okay? And it wouldn't make any difference
as to whether or not I could mock them. What a [__]
concept, bro. >> You pre-watched so hard, man. I made this
argument before I pulled this up. You don't have to pre-watch
it. I I was making this argument like 30 minutes ago. It's so
stupid to say, "Oh, it's actually hypocritical." Under that under
that same stance, every single person who's misogynistic is gay.
And that's everybody in commentary. So, everybody in commentary
is gay under that standard. It's insane. It's a totally deranged
standard. It doesn't make any sense. It would be so stupid to
even pretend that that is appropriate,
>> dude.
Okay. I'm actually not interested in trans people, okay? I'm
not chasing anyone, right? But if I'm flirting with a woman now,
right now
Oh, wait. Hold on. A woman. I thought he [laughter] was
h Chud stands on business. Says his trans chasing does not matter.
My My transchasing is irrelevant.
the persistent and never fading transchasing that he does. Okay.
>> Does that mean that I can't mock women? Does that mean
it's a problem for me to mock women?
>> Like he's too to even make the argument. Okay. The >> Oh,
he says the same thing. >> The actual argument you would
make. >> Why did this guy just copy me? So is about my
change in political perspective on some of these topics.
And as I say, that's up for the audience to decide whether or
not they feel that my change in perspective on certain topics
over the course of a 5year time span covering these topics is
genuine or not. That's up for the audience to decide at the end
of the day. >> Trans women are women.
Uh posttop, sure,
I'll give you that posttop.
Hop. How do you go to How you going to go to third base with
a trans woman say you're not gay? Okay. Preop trans woman. I'm
sorry.
It's just obvious. Okay.
I it it is the way it is, man. >> But it literally makes
no as to whether you're flirting with a particular identity of
people who you are then mocking like that day, let alone over
the course of nearly six years. Anyway,
it's seriously par parody levels with this guy. So, I don't know,
just going to ignore it and don't want to give attention to it
because this guy is beyond shameless. So, yeah. I mean, my point
with Liam is that it seems quite transparent that he's had a
very swift,
quick change in not just beliefs, but seemingly principles
that have happened over a very, very short time span that seem
to coincide with him moving towards a new genre of YouTube like
the music YouTube side of things, which does tend to have a lower
and for one of a better word, more woke and soy audience. So
that to me is the difference.
That to me is the difference. >> Yeah. Monetary incentive.
>> But at the end of the day, you guys can determine that.
Now, there is one thing that I will address more conclusively,
and I've already leaked these DMs on Twitter, but I'll go over
them now. Okay? I'll go over them. Now, he outright said to me
that he >> Okay, this is this is like uh this is why
not not cool with some of the people in this. Chud Lar wants
an alpha chaser like you to dominate his little busy.
This person is disturbed. This person is deranged. This person
is unhealthy.
Okay. Oh, hold on. You can't really see it from this angle
there. That that that
person probably just needs to be banned. Okay. That person needs
to >> not lies about get that person out >> and will
continue to lie about me when I talk to him in DMs. Should we
have a little look at those DMs and you can see what you think
about this exchange. Okay. So, I did mention this before.
I did mention this before. There was a time a few weeks ago where
um Liam Donovan Lex came into my chat and said that he'd sent
me a DM. Okay.
So, I was in the middle of streaming and I noted that he sent
me a DM
and so I started responding to him. So, this is actually what
the exchange looks like. Okay.
Wanted to forward this to you so it's not like a surprise if
you catch wind of it. But yeah, I've been getting a bunch of
posts for a while about this video and have my thoughts on it.
And you can see here there's a thumbnail which says lollycon
lyrics. >> Your chat's covering everything. >> Old
look and then an arrow to his new
>> with Liam Donovan and then fraud question mark. Right.
And then the title is Liam Donovan lyrics is trying to hide his
past. So that is that is the DK presentation of that video. Okay.
Now I've got to be honest with you.
I can't actually recall what I said in that video.
Okay. And it could be that there is some inongruence
between the presentation and what I say. >> And that is
>> uh private hug. Thank you. gifted sub. I think that
adds another hour to the stream. Thank you very much.
Uh let's see here. 1 hour five. Boom. >> Simply a product
DK doing the thumbnail and titling. But as always, I take full
for what's on there. Okay. And on top of that as well,
I'm a reasonable guy.
I'm a reasonable guy. Okay. Whilst this is a provocative title
and thumbnail, okay, I do not think it is completely out of the
realms of of you know the [clears throat] reality
to frame it in this way. However, if it's a problem, I'm willing
to have a conversation.
>> so dude, I was I was just totally correct in everything
I said about this.
Everything I Dude,
I feel like I'm just
correct. that like, hey, if you just came to him and weren't
like, hey, I'm going to talk about your past if you talk about
my past, if you hadn't done that, if you hadn't come to the the
negotiating table with a gun,
Chud would have talked to you. Chud would have been like reasonable.
He could have gone, you know, maybe lollycon passed, maybe lolly
past, we change the title, we make it a little less offensive.
He might have even been willing to change the title entirely
because the video is like old, right? Like I think the video
was old even when Lar brought it up to him.
So
yeah, I man I I think that's what it is. You came to the negotiating
table with a gun. You made a threat, a a veiled threat, a very
veiled threat of well, I'm going to talk about your drama, right?
It's just a double standard, man. It's just a double standard.
I don't know what else to say. Uh yeah, you're threatening me
and you can't win if you threaten me. >> Approaching this
with me. >> Can't let it happen. >> My thought process
is that what's he looking for? What does he want here? Maybe
we can talk about it and figure something out. That's my kind
of entry >> Hold on. Hold on. Queen says he spoke to Aiden
about this combo afterwards, by the way. >> Uh, what is
that referring to? What did he say to Aiden about a sec? Okay.
>> Yes. In the past, I have changed titles and thumbnails
because there was ages ago at this point someone contacted me
and said, "Hey, you've put the thumbnail up like this and there's
people from my real life that are contacting me about it. Could
you change it?" and we changed it. You know, there's been multiple
times with a title and author. >> Larry brought a knife
to a gunfight. Well, unfortunately for Lar, he's like giga debuffed
here because in terms of what his audience thinks is fair tactics
or what he can say, he's like hyper debuffed. So, he could he
could bring a gun in his world and it is like a
it's like a potato peeler in Ch's world. Chad can say whatever
the he wants. his audience will accept anything he does like
no matter what, right? Anything he says and doesn't do like he
could say anything and they'll accept it. Lar does not have that
same luxury. So he can he's totally limited. He can't really
have this fight. He's like fighting with both hands tied behind
his back if he wants to try to have this fight. So it's stupid
to just to not just go to Chad and try to say like, "Hey man,
I just don't I feel like this is really unfair unfair characterization.
Would you mind changing it?" And I think you get somewhere. But
when you go here and you This guy's got some drama, too. And
I could talk about it. >> Thumbnail has been changed. And
I'm still open to it. I'm still open to it. Well, no, it's not
about being Well, you can say I'm It's sometimes just understanding
that what could be a funny joke or a meme,
could be like
a problem for someone. And you've got to just kind of be reasonable
about it if it is quite extreme. And you know it is a very provocative
framing of the situation. So I'm open to having a discussion
and seeing you know what needs to happen because the other thing
to bear in mind with this as well is like at this point you know
uh I will say for both Chud and Queen I think this is an issue
they have where they get so annoyed with the way somebody's going
about something that they look past the fact that they can see
what they want and they could like bridge that gap and make the
conversation fine. They get like so annoyed with the way someone
approaches them that they're like, "Oh, [__] you
forever."
I do think there's something to be said for like they could say,
"It sounds like you like if Chud said, "It sounds like you want
me to change the title." Is that what you want? I think there
could have just been no like no strife here at all, but then
there's no content here. So, I mean, double-edged sword, right?
in terms of if this was a professional workplace, maybe Chud
totally does that and he's like totally socially capable and
he's aware of this, right? Maybe maybe he just does this because
it leads to like, you know, friction in content possibly. I don't
think so, though. It seems like more of a principled thing. At
least it's definitely a principled thing with Queenman. I think
with Chud, I don't I'm not 100% sure. Maybe he just maybe he
knows about this and maybe he would be socially aware in a situation
where he had to be, but he knows that it's like beneficial to
handle things this way
There's also things where it can you can have bad experiences
when you handle things in like the socially normal way because
a lot of people online are maladaptive as and they'll know how
to manipulate the general social situation in their favor and
they will be like unknowingly manipulative at all times and you
get a you get taken advantage of like two or three times in this
way and you immediately go okay never again
never again
so I don't know which one it is for Chud I've not really covered
uh >> sorry I don't know which one it is for Chud if he's
socially aware and just doesn't want to do it because it's content
or if he's like been kind of over by helping people who are just
openly manipulative like this like it's probably a huge red flag
when you see somebody who comes in and does the threat the subtle
threat hey we should talk about this isn't it kind of unfair
you know what needs to happen because the other thing to bear
in mind with this as well is like at this point you know I've
not really covered um lyrics that much, you know? So, I'm not
really like looking to like
>> you have to remember he's doing a stream at the same
time of these DMs.
Oh, well, I didn't that's not clear from the DMs that he's doing
a stream at the same
Like these DMs were not happening recently, but if if you're
saying that back here is live while he's responding to lyrics,
that is kind of weird. >> Bury him and him over. And I'm
like, you know, if this is really causing him a problem, then
yeah, we can figure something out. >> Oh, he says that
at the start. I missed that at the start. Critical information.
Critical information. I missed it if he said it at the start.
>> Nonetheless, Nonetheless, continuing on. Okay, continuing
on. >> I missed that if that was here. >> So, he
put this post in. >> Although, I also think um I might
have started in the middle of the segment. Yeah, I've had a number
of people ask about this video, unfortunately, because the thumbnail
and title is a blatant lie purposely made to give my new followers
a bad impression. The video is just reacting to the Rose Malay
video all the way back when that happened when she told provable
lies that she's admitted to. And I've talked about all that on
stream when it happened. So, yeah, it's made as purposeful bait
to create posts like what you're making right now. I mean, I
wouldn't say it's to create bait to create posts like this. It's
more so just
DK thought it would be very funny to present it in this way.
I don't think he's thought, oh yes, if I do this, it's going
to end up getting posted on Lar's subreddit.
It's like just DK being DK. Again, I take responsibility for
it, but it's just to say that the intent is not, oh yeah, let's
get it on the subreddit and then it will [__] him
over. You know, my genuine perspective is, you know, I don't
if he genuinely is having issues off of this, we can find a solution
that works for him that means we still get to keep the video
up in a way that, you know, doesn't completely walk back the
flavor of what's happening, if that makes sense, right? But the
intent is not let's get something on his subreddit to [__]
them over. That's not the idea here in spite of what he says.
Anyway,
I don't know if I should make a big post on this subreddit just
clarifying it or address it like this. But yeah, of course it's
annoying when someone knowingly lies about you, which especially
doesn't make sense cuz this guy's been accused of being a before
multiple times for being like [laughter] 37 talking to an 18-year-old
who ended up being 17 but lied about her age during co. So given
the fact that he knows it's frustrating to deal with people lying
about him. >> Didn't he read this post already >> in
like the craziest, most reputation destroying way? I don't know.
Oh, maybe he didn't. Hold on. This isn't the one. Oh, this isn't
the one where he talks about him being 40 and obsessed >> or
he engages in the same behavior.
>> oh, right, right, right. Cuz that's that's recent and
this is going back in time. My bad. My bad. >> This messing
up the time. >> My thought process is, okay, well, if it's
causing me problems, maybe we can have a conversation and figure
something out. So, nonetheless, continuing on, don't think I'm
saying anything unreasonable or even antagonist.
Um, the feeling I get from this is it is Chud saying, "No, it
is Chud saying, "Hey, if you want me to take my knee off your
neck, ask me to do it." And Lar goes, "No, I just want you to
admit I just want you to admit it's unfair that your knee's on
my neck. I just want you to admit it's unfair." And Chun's like,
"I don't care about that debate. Off. If you want something,
ask me for it." And Lar goes, "No, I just want you to say it's
like unfair. It's like a double standard. It's like really unreasonable."
And Chan's like, "I don't care about a DM debate about that.
ask me for what you want. And lyrics refuses to ask directly
for what he wants. He's being very indirect. He is saying, "Oh,
I just want you to say it's like unfair that this is happening.
It's like it's unfair. Don't you agree it's unfair?" Sorry, this
is Lyric's new trans voice. Okay. Don't you agree it's unfair
that you're doing this?
And Chud's like, I don't give a about talking about whether it's
fair. If you want me to change it, just ask.
And Lar refuses to do so. istic by bringing up your allegations.
Just a double standard, but if I'm mistaken, let me know. It
was more of an offline thing, but yeah, not trying to start anything,
just needed to address it to people after multiple times it was
brought up. Hey man, that was more my editor popping off, but
obviously it's my channel. I don't really have an issue with
this. I wouldn't have even known about it if you hadn't sent
it to me. So, my thought process here is he's putting a Reddit
post to his community. I don't really care that much about this.
Like it seems like >> Yeah. The fact that Chud's in the
middle of stream adds like a different wrinkle to this. Although
I would say if you're in the middle of the stream, I don't know
how you would respond to this.
I feel like he's giving like a pretty big response for being
in the middle of
I feel like but me when somebody brings something up that's like
serious to me, I would go, "Hey, I'm uh I'm streaming off for
a minute. Why is Chud leaking these DMs?" because Larry on his
subreddit said Chud lied to him multiple times in DMs and said
he was going to keep lying about him. So Lar said that Chud said
verbatim to Lar or something along the lines of yeah I am lying
about you and I'm going to keep lying about you off and that's
not what Chud logic said in these DMs. So Chud's leaking the
DMs cuz he feels like he was lied about like he's approaching
me to say oh I've said this stuff about you is that okay? And
obviously the other thing you need to bear in mind with this
too, right? I'm not looking to endlessly talk about something
that happened in 2020.
I'm not looking to argue the toss and debate
a controversy I was involved in in 2020. I'm so beyond it now.
I literally do not care if it gets bought up in some way. Like
Noah Samson brought it up in a video one time and it was obviously
annoying to [__] deal with that, but whatever. I'm
past it. you know, I'm just looking to move forward as I have
been with my life, my channel, my content, etc. So, it's it's
like, you know, obviously I don't want to constantly get wrote
back into endlessly talking about something that happened in
2020.
So, my perspective here is like whatever, dude. You do you, you
know,
and so [clears throat] on. And I thought that would be the end
of it cuz it seemed like he just wanted to let me know that he'd
said this. But then he
"Okay, I hear you. I of course know the whole DK meme meme, but
if Noah Samson made a video with a thumbnail and title, >> guys,
guys, guys, we've we've hit the statute of limitations on the
pedal allegations. Okay, we've hit the statute of limitations.
I need you to stop talking about it. Stop talking about it cuz
we hit the statute. You can no longer accuse me. Okay, I beat
the 5-year mark. It's over.
>> Logic is covering up his past and you obviously would
be mad and call him out for lying. Uh, by the way, I don't think
he's a I think people accuse him of being a while not really
being informed, but that is Yeah, that'll happen. That'll happen
>> about you. >> I think listen 2018
2017 Destiny was the most based. Okay. Where he was like, "Oh,
if you're just going to constantly troll near the line and then
you go over the line, I don't really have sympathy for you."
It's a little bit like that, right? If you're going to constantly
troll right near the line, now I don't know if Tread was constant,
but it's just like you have you got a stream, you got an online
presence, don't take a risk. Although, with regards to, you know,
suspicious actions with regards to stuff like that, maybe I shouldn't
throw the first stone. But hey, we're all we're all human. We
all make mistakes. >> Would you buy the excuse of, "Oh,
that wasn't me. It wasn't my editor." Like, it wouldn't change
anything is all I'm
>> like I >> I do think that if Lar had to go to
Chud's chat and say, "Hey, look at DMs real quick." Um, he should
have expected to be totally ranked for this. Yeah, he should
have expected to be totally for this. Um, Chad flirted with someone
who was 18 when he was 34. I think like that's just
that's just weird, but it's it's like not illegal. That's all.
I I have I like judgment for people who will people that much
younger when they're 35, 34, whatever. I I do think it's like
weird, but it's not judgment as in like your that weird. also
would depend on the I haven't read the whole DM so maybe it was
just like hey I think your stream is funny and I'm gonna send
you some nudes or something and maybe Chad was super into that
I don't know of course I'm fine with you criticizing on me insulting
etc but I know you don't think about this about me and like I'm
going under my real name now and to just have one of those top
videos show up as Liam Dolphin hides his past especially when
you know it's just a bait lie
just kind of up I guess so at this point I'm
sent me another bit of text. I was like, I can't be [__]
with. Not trying to start anything. Just needed to be mad and
call him out for lying about you. Would you buy the excuse of,
"Oh, that wasn't me. It wasn't my editor." >> [__]
Was this about where we were? >> Like it wouldn't change
anything is all I'm saying. Like I of course I'm fine with you
criticizing on me, insulting,
>> But I know you don't think about this about me and like
I'm going under my real name now. And to just have one of those
top videos show up as Liam Dolphin hides his
>> Okay. No, that is where we're
lie
>> just kind of [__] up, I guess. So, at this
point, I'm thinking, well, what the [__] do you want?
Like, what do you want me to do about this? Exactly.
Okay. So, also the other thing as well is like, is it a lie to
say he's got a past?
>> I feel like the stuff was overblown as
was he gonna thread the needle on on this because I think the
title should be representative of your opinion and I think Chud's,
you know, the the editor shield the editor shield conundrum is
that I don't think Chud's opinion gets represented all the time.
I think sometimes DK's opinion gets gets represented, right?
And so it's not actually indicative of what Chud thinks. It's
indicative of what DK thinks. And so Chud does consider to be
then why did he say it's overblown? If he thinks lyrics is genu
genuinely
if he thinks if he thinks lyrics has a genuinely past why does
he believe it's overblown? Quala Todd does consider to be okay.
So if he Okay. So he didn't think he is a So do you think you
think there's a lot of people with past that you're not insinuating
our you think insinuating somebody has a past doesn't insinuate
their I'm just just really quick I just need somebody to tell
me does insinuating somebody has a past insinuate their and if
Chud believes that then why did he say oh well I think it's overblown
because you can either think this guy's genuinely like got some
red flags of
or you can believe it's overblown that's my opinion Right. And
I understand there's like a needle to thread there. Okay. I get
it.
I do get it. But I just don't think I think probably the title's
a little like a little off from his opinion. And I think that's
why he was willing to have the conversation. Lyrics just went
about it the entirely wrong
He could be a non-offending. He was saying he shouldn't be cancelled.
that you think that was Chudlo Logic's opinion that Liam Donovan
is a non-offending
and he could determine that and that that's what he meant by
overblown that well he is a he's a non-offending
that's what you think Bonstein that's a ludicrous comment >> I've
said but he does have a controversy in his past that's just a
reality >> oh that's what I that's that's what I
that you could switch this over to you know Liam Donovan lyrics
is trying to hide you could go Lyrics just trying to hide his
past and you could take the name out, right? Realistically,
probably if you just take Liam Donovan out of the name, that
might be okay. That might be enough. That might be the thing
that pisses him off most is that it says Liam Donovan instead
of lyrics.
>> That's That is a fact. He was embroiled in a controversy
involving
in his career. >> Hold on. This is a crazy comment, Missy.
The problem is the average person hears and thinks childh.
No, I don't think that's the problem. I think I think probably
people use especially because it evokes that and that is the
explicit intention of the person who made this title. That's
not that's not the problem,
right? The problem here is am I wrong? Yeah, you're wrong that
that's the problem. People might think that, but that's not the
problem. The problem here is the person who made the title is
trying to evoke that explicitly. I know it doesn't mean that.
Well, no, it means that to most people. So, if you just say,
"I know it doesn't mean that." Talking about a dictionary definition,
that's to most people, it does mean that. And that's why it's
being used here. So, it's not the problem. It is the intention.
And again, I'm not looking to argue toss about this, bro. It's
2020. This happened with me. I don't want to argue about my alleged
past where someone who used to have a controversy about I do
not care. I just want a solution, bro. So, I ask him. I say to
him, I mean, what are you looking for here? Okay, I say what
are you looking for here? Because my thought process at this
stage is he's going to ask for a title change, a thumbnail change,
or something like that. Okay. >> Yeah, that's what he wants.
That's what he want. >> So, I'm thinking sure, I'm open
to that if you want me to amend the title, the thumbnail. I mean,
you know, if it's really that bad, private the video. I mean,
I don't really care. It's like an old video, you know, it's 5
months old. It's run its course. It's not going to garner particularly
many new views, I don't think. So, I'm open to
>> Hold on.
I will say I had a previous criticism here that I didn't know
if Chud like couldn't tell that this is what he wanted and was
getting annoyed cuz lyrics was being like slightly manipulative
manipulative.
But given that he was streaming,
I can now understand his reactions entirely. why he's like very
short, why he's very like impatient, why he's very much like,
"Hey, why the [__] are you messaging me right now?"
That makes total sense to me now. And I don't have like any judgment
there anymore. Like that judgment is totally gone cuz it's really
obvious to me that like, okay, if you're streaming, this is incredibly
patient
and he's just kind of being an [__] Okay, I'm open
to a discussion about what needs to
>> but instead of telling me like, I don't know, well,
could you change the title, you know, could you amend this? Could
you amend that? He starts trying to debate. HE TRIES TO DEBATE
ME, BRO. I DON'T care about your debate. Like, just tell me what
you want me to do and I'll consider it. That's it. I guess at
least an acknowledgement of a double standard, I guess. It just
doesn't make sense to me. an understanding, I guess. Like, do
you get where I'm coming from or
I don't know. Do you think it's unreasonable to point this out,
especially considering what you have dealt with? And so, I'm
a bit exacerbated at this. Aren't we kindred spirits, Chudlogic?
Aren't we both pedophile adjacent? Chudlogic, aren't we kindred
spirits in the realm? Could you not do me a favor as one adjacent
man to another? Could you not do me a favor, Chudlogic? That's
what he's going for here. Kind of weird. kind of weird. Kind
of weird. >> Bear in mind as well, this is whilst I'm streaming,
too. Okay, this is whilst I'm streaming as well. So, I'm trying
to focus on that. They send me these [__] messages.
It's, you know, quite frustrating to to deal with some needy
in your DMs when you're trying to focus on streaming. So, I'm
like, make whatever point you want, man. Just funny. >> Oh,
Trump must have had a good idea. He must have had a high tier
future trans radar. That's why he's so patient here. He's like,
"This will be a this will be a delectable little morsel at some
point in the next 6 months or so. So, I'm going to be very patient
with him or him her." That that must have been that explains
everything >> that you want to turn your back on your past
and act like it never happened. You weren't joking about etc
to plate your weirdo teeny bop audience and you have now. Now,
you want to have some private debate about whether or not you're
making a fair point. I don't care, bro. Which is true. I do not
care. I do not care to argue the toss about whether or not I'm
a hypocrite in DMs whilst >> is the video quality at 1080p
for the VOD. Oh, yeah. Maybe >> whilst I'm streaming, okay,
about some 5-month old video in reference to a drama that I was
in brought in in 2020. 2021. I do not care, bro. I don't care
about this. That's why I'm saying, "What are you looking for
here? Tell me what you want. You want me to change the title,
thumbnail,
private the video, let's talk about it." But instead, he's trying
to debate me. And I think it's like that's the outcome that he
wants. He wants me to change it in some way, but he's too afraid
to say it. So instead, he just goes around the houses with this,
and I'm just like, dude, I just don't care,
you know? And at this point, I focus on my stream, you know?
obviously over the days, forget about this conversation and that's
it essentially.
And I've got to be honest with you,
this is the first time I've actually read this. I skimmed over
it briefly, but this is the first time I've actually read this
DM because when I saw that he sent me another bit of text, I
was like, I can't be for this and I didn't really read it properly.
So, let's read this. Not trying to make this aggressive and it
wasn't planning on getting into all your other critiques, but
to quickly sum it off, I of course find jokes funny, but made
the decision to not be the guy who makes review jokes, especially
publicly, because I don't want to be that guy.
And overall, as a person at 20, wanted to change who I am and
how I portray myself.
I don't think that's an unreasonable thing to believe,
but you can or not.
Regardless, I was strictly talking about the thing because it
is the most extreme and blatant lie. But if you don't care about
lying, then the convo stops, I guess, stops here.
I don't know how this standard you can ever be upset when other
people call you. So, just wanted to get your reasoning here,
but there isn't any. That's all I wanted to bring up. Where am
I admitting to lying, bro?
The thing I >> He says you're lying if you don't respond.
You didn't respond. don't care about is having a debate about
this.
>> I'm not looking to have a debate.
Where's the lie? Where, dude? Where am I saying I don't care
about lying or I lied about you? In fact, so but if you don't
care about lying, then the combo, I guess, stops here and the
convo stopped there. He said, I mean, like it's a totally preposterous
reason to say somebody's like committed to lying about you, but
that is his reasoning. I think this is right here. But if you
don't care about lying, then the combo stops here, I guess. I
guess it stops here. So stupid, dude. So stupid. Oh my god, bro.
Well, exactly. And that's fine if he wants to take it that way,
but to put out publicly and to claim what was it again? What
was it he claimed?
To claim outright said to outright said to me that he lies about
me and will continue to lie about me when I talk to him in DMs.
points to the point where I outright say to him I lie about him
and will continue to lie about him. Where's that in the DMs exactly?
Where's that in the DMs? It's not there.
It's not there because it didn't happen, dude. Because it never
happened because even if I did think like that, which I don't,
I would not admit to that in DMs. So yeah, obviously I'm not
going to make any changes to the video. Even if you ask me now,
he can get no people will learn about your past, Liam. Very unfortunate.
Very unfortunate as you continue to grow. [laughter] But you
know, I I just I don't really feel like I've I mean, I get it's
a provocative framing and I get him being annoyed about it.
But like I said to I I feel like [laughter] I said quite plainly,
I mean, what are you looking for here? I mean, what are you looking
for here? Like [laughter] what what are you looking for, bro?
I'm opening it up, you know? I mean, the way I see it is like
I could easily I could easily see that as changing to like past
that that could be a change because that is not as provocative
and more accurate to the circumstances because he does have,
you know, a previous history
of
controversy. So it could change to fast, you know, I mean, you
know, if it was the case that at this stage in October, because
bear in mind this is this is UK dates from my screenshot. This
is back in October.
If it was the case
that this video was causing him loads of problems and
I would potentially even been open to privacying the video or
unlisting the video perhaps.
is not really any skin off my nose because I genuinely am not
in in this to, you know, have stuff out there that ruins Liam
Donovan's career.
>> Yeah. Also, the fact that it was like 5 months old,
I do think Tread would have a lot of leeway there, right? It's
not like it was going to get a significant number of views after
that,
unless Lyrics like totally blows up and it doesn't matter anymore
for him >> I don't care. It's like whatever, dude. It was
a funny thing to cover at the time. And it was a provocative,
funny framing,
but I'm not out to like destroy his career. I don't care about
his career. You know, it's obviously irritating that he's dishonest
in my perspective and how he's moved on, but whatever. Go and
make your money. Go and do your music stuff. So, I just don't
understand his logic here of, you know, responding to this post
and just saying that isn't true about me. So, yeah,
that's it. That's the drama. That's it. Um, [clears throat] Queenman
mentioned in chat that Aiden
had said to him, I guess, or did he speak about it publicly about
Lyrics approaching him? >> He talked about it. I didn't
remember Chud getting brought up in that conversation, but maybe
I missed it at the time stamp. >> And we're going to be
doing it all again tomorrow, guys. We're going to be
>> shout out to this is this is the video. >> Shout
out to the guys.
>> Hold on, hold on, hold on.
>> Me when the fellas make me dress up like a girl to them
off. Why? Why did he tweet this? You look like a lady
me. Do me [laughter]
>> tell [screaming] me cheek dear
follow me.
>> Oh, this tweet. Imagine you're a Roman soldier getting
back from battle. You're all sweaty, pent up, and dirty. And
as you're heading to the nearest stream to wash yourself, you
see the Roman tow sneaks glances at you like this. What you doing?
Bust that [__] wide open.
>> Oh my god.
>> Win edit. Okay. Um, what's going on there? What is all
that about?
So, there was also another post which addressed the idea of
>> sadly you're
jump to Kuiman posts. He is and will always be a
Well, I mean, you know, I was going to say shout out to the basically.
>> I was going to say shout out to the because because
they're going to be feeding for a few days off of this, I'm
You need to let people know that the uncensored take is here.
Okay. But I will be talking about it on YouTube tomorrow as well
in a YouTube or Twitch
>> I'll be real. I did not feel when Chud said the f slur.
I still I just have to put it on the record. I didn't feel it.
didn't feel sincere.
Felt kind of felt kind of forced. Felt like, "Oh, I have to I
have to do something for Kick that's special and unique."
I I didn't feel it, man. I'm just >> Format. Obviously,
though, don't flag or report the video. It causes more trouble
than good. >> Right. Right. Right. Right. Right. I I basically
didn't even engage with that part of the post. >> Far more
legitimate things to criticize him over. Like what I said above,
it's never good to get into a reporting flagging battle. I mean,
you know, it's fair enough. It just feels like he's more concerned
with the consequences of getting into a battle like that rather
than saying it's wrong to report someone's video, you know, on
on these grounds because I mean he himself has absolutely
in the past reacted to stuff in his content and he's a music
channel too like he relies on,
you know, very good gra the good graces of being able to react
to music and absolutely in a glass house. So yeah, guys, any
questions? I think I've kind of covered all of that really. Did
Aiden talk about this at all? I mean, I'm >> Oh, when Kai
and Tom were dating, Tom was also painting his nails and wearing
some rather strange outfits. However, I imagine Tom didn't start
to wear full-on makeup due to the community he was in. I don't
know if you guys can see that chat message from Infixed. You
cannot highlighted chat message from Chud's chat. There's a lot
of a lot of legs to that whole, you know, Kai ruined lyrics just
like she tried to ruin Tom theory. I'm up. I'm I'm open to
>> We've been hearing that. >> I don't think I think
Ano is way less bad for Idubbbz than I think Idubbbz was always
this person. I think Idubbbz underneath it all was always the
guy he is now. I don't think Larry was always the guy he is now.
I think L was changed. Like sorry, not Kai. Um Idubbbz was always
going to be that guy.
Ana whe whether Ana existed or not, I think he was always going
to be that guy. I think Kai Kai did some actual soul manipulation.
It's up >> if as we're on kick and you know could be fun.
>> Yeah, but somehow Lyrics is making more money as Liam.
Um yeah, cuz Brad Taste died and somebody had to fill that slot.
Oh, Riy not a good look with that avatar by the way.
Letting you know I went a whole rant >> talked about his
experience or on his stream. Did he? What did he say? I actually
briefly communicated with Aiden over this because Aiden is a
respectable individual
that doesn't leak his own. >> He's but well other people
can sometimes leak his DMs I guess but
>> woman on here is stupid. >> I was just factual.
It wasn't meant to imply anything >> every single day.
>> What was okay? >> Um the deeper is that the Dark
Souls tweet or is that something related to this Queen? cuz the
Dark Souls tweet was peak. That's maybe the funniest thing I
saw today. This is this is precisely what I pointed out earlier.
I said explicitly, okay, that we shouldn't even entertain this
because given Chud's past, I don't really trust his community.
And I think I think a lot of people are way too into that Aiden
picture to joke about it. I think it's actually like Deep just
straight up admitting the thing I hypothesized. Thank you, Deep.
He knows himself. Okay, Deep is a level five in in Britney Simon's
world. Deepama is a level five. Okay, he knows himself. He knows
himself
>> Hold on. >> Reban Rubin donated $3. Anyone make
any larynx jokes about this Lar guy yet? >> I don't believe
anybody's made a larynx joke about lyrics. Rean Rubin, I don't
think this happened. Okay. Yeah, Britney Simon already made a
clear out of luring in men with looks alone. Well, was it looks
or
what? Dude,
Queen guy just show up to link a bunch of Deeperama tweets and
[__] off or what? What is this? I stood for my chair
and perfectly levitated into the air for exactly 10 minutes when
I found out Kai's name was actually short for Caitlyn. Okay.
Okay. The full body shock. God,
>> the memes are good.
>> God. Okay. I think that's We're getting
near the end of this.
>> I don't know. I don't know what else we got. Oh, wait.
Hold on. No, no, no, no, no. We're not near the end of this.
Oh, we can actually go over the stuff a little bit. Okay.
>> Who's Whose video is this? Perry video. >> It's
not a Perry video. Larry is a pathetic loser.
So, apparently some people Can we just doom scroll deeper on
my Twitter? I already do that. But I think there's um
I think basically this video goes over all the lyrics stuff.
Okay, that video ran lyrics offline for a bit. Well, I was told
this is the the authoritative
lyrics video. Okay, that if you want to if you want to actually
go look into this, you will you'll be disturbed.
He actually a pervert. Well, I mean
>> it really depends. You are my favorite YouTuber ever.
H. What's up, guys? Welcome back. This is a little weird because
it's three years old and I've never heard of this person. This
person just quit the internet or what? >> What is up, guys?
>> Yeah, they just quit the internet. Damn.
>> They just like they showed up, they dropped the video.
>> No video did as well, and then they pieced out.
>> What? What a guy. That's crazy. This guy This guy dropped
in, did a lyrics video, lyrics hit piece, and then pretty promptly
off.
Kind of wild. Oh, wait. Hold on. What is this? Oh, no. It's just
saying you hadn't uploaded in a while. I
>> We keep >> back to a new video. And today we're
going to be bashing honestly this kid that I've wanted to bash
for quite a bit now. Now, to be fair to Lyrics, uh, back whenever
the whole Jaden drama happened, he actually stood up and kind
of defended me to a certain extent in his >> And most recently,
Jaden threatened to flag the videos. >> This is India music.
>> Yeah, my YouTube music seems to have gone into some
Bollywood music, some Bollywood mix. I don't know how this happened.
must have detected that I live in Canada and decided to try to
provide me with something that would be commensurate with my
interests and tastes.
I don't know why this happened. I don't know how this happened.
>> Yeah, I was way ahead of you, Revoked. Unfortunately,
you can't make the joke after I make the joke. I already leaned
into it. Okay, let's check it out. >> I was making content
criticizing her. Very similar to what I'm doing right now in
this video. He had this to say on Twitter. That was not trustworthy.
referring to the smaller commentator. He's transphobic and constantly
makes videos on me and Scrimzox. What I do know is that whatever
Scrimzox, >> bro, so many of these people stream for so
long before I ever started. It's >> did wasn't enough to
be arrested and that Scrimox addressed this years ago when it
happened and people moved on. Scrim's making a new vid soon.
And I know none of that makes sense for the context of this video
because this conversation stemmed from a different drama that's
completely irrelevant that you don't need to know the details
of. It was a whole bunch of gay. NOTHING IMPORTANT.
OH, [screaming] WHAT?
WAIT, I thought you're not supposed to use gay as a pjorative.
Didn't he just chastise Aiden for this? He literally just chastised
Aiden for this. Using gay as a pjorative? That's soed up, man.
So Grimsy, who is the smaller YouTuber, said, "I don't like you
because you're a bad person.
Not because you're trans. Jesus, you're proving it literally
right now." And Jaden responds, "I could report you for some
of the you've said. I don't know how a channel like yours is
allowed anymore." Where he responds saying, "I think we're done
here, dickhead." And Jaden finishes off saying, "Yeah, we are.
Keep making videos on me and watch what happens." And while I
do appreciate that, dude, you're still gay as
[__] Now, to put this into perspective, Larry is
the kind of guy that will openly call other people online gay.
Cringe, [snorts] and meanwhile, at the same time wearing a anime
sweatshirt with an anime girl on it. Pretty oy gay stuff if you
brother got a Toridora t-shirt. Not >> That's me. Pretty
gay stuff if you ask me. This guy's no balls. This guy's no balls.
What happened to balls nowadays? Did everybody did everybody
turn trans? Did everybody go to a woman? I mean, nothing wrong
with it, but Jesus. I'm just trying to find out, man. I'm just
trying to get >> Dude, no way. Oh my goodness. This is
one of those videos that hits way harder in retrospect. What
the the data? This guy's no balls. This guy has no balls. This
guy has no balls. What happened to my balls these days? Did everybody
>> Is everyone trans nowadays? Nothing wrong with it, but
you know what? [__] He just did Did everybody just
turn trans or something? Not that there's anything wrong with
that, but I'm just trying to collect the data like Jesus. Pretty
gay stuff if you ask me. >> So, saying lyrics has a little
bit of an an infatuation with anime is kind of underelling it.
He has an entire second channel where he made videos talking
about every single judu.
>> This guy
has made so many successful channels. Like, these views are crazy.
What the [__] He's like actually made a real career
of just being a consistent YouTuber. That's >> our second
channel where he made videos talking about every single judu.
Now, if you're some sort of weeaboo fat and you actually know
what that means, by all means, go ahead and tell me. I really
don't care. As you guys know, I'm not a big fan of anime. Actually,
I hate everyone who watches and I want to curb stomp you into
the pavement. But he uploaded quite a few videos onto this channel
that were >> Man, this guy was ahead of his time. That
might have been that might have been a edgy thing to say three
years ago, but damn, he's like he's right. He's just hit the
curve now. Where'd this guy go? This guy just disappeared. Pretty
gay, if I do say so myself. >> Remember, you have just
one life. So, don't choose a road that's impossible.
It doesn't matter what you do if you live and die as you like.
However, no matter what route you end up taking, remember to
protect the people that are precious to you, the ones you appreciate
the very most. >> Bro, how do people watch dubbed anime?
Like, actually, what is wrong with
>> And trust and love with all your heart. Do you have
people like that in your >> Do you have people like that,
too? >> Yes, I do. Of course. >> Really? Who? Who?
>> Who's got that? >> Well, I have my grandson.
Cuz he got that.
Cuz he's got that.
>> He's got that. >> Have all the people in this
>> got that
you cuz you got it was at fault for a huge chunk of it. No problem.
Whether it be directly or indirectly >> got that you
>> I don't why. Yeah, it's the Medicare
>> You got that. >> This is one of Lyric's videos.
I'm >> pretty gay stuff if you ask me. And for any of you
wondering that maybe that this video that I cherrypicked from
his channel of course is like a very old video that he uploaded
a while ago. It was uploaded last month. So well after he was
calling everybody else gay
and cringe and then he upload like this. Now, this is one thing,
and it's not necessarily a ton to go off of, and I'm not trying
to make this entire video just about this cringe animation, but
there is an entire other part of this that makes this animation
10 times worse. I genuinely think I have leukemia after seeing
these images. So, just to warn you, oh boy, this is going to
be his entire Twitter feed. Hold on. Ry wants me to take a look
at his some like lyrics archive channel
>> episode five. There's another chain >> that pulled
this pulled some lyrics video. Okay. This anime ruined its potential
in the dumbest way. Lar's
>> Jean Sigiri scene and elf is show. >> Wait, wait,
wait. Date unknown. Hold on. Date unknown. Oh no, no, no [__]
off. >> Episode five. >> Give me a second. Date unknown.
It says nothing else. I I would want to know when this changing
Sigiri scene and elf is showing her panties to Sigiri. But don't
worry guys, it's okay. It's not weird. I swear because uh Sigiri
needs to see them to take her artistry skill to the next level.
>> Unironically for research purposes. And as I said before,
this is just the plot in the story at the time with Sigiri hitting
a wall on drawing and needing new inspiration to take her drawings
for Masamune to the next level resulting in her seeking out panties.
This is basically the training arc of the show, but instead of
spending time refining, honing your new abilities, you're just
harassing girls. Truly the gigachad path, young padawan. Oh yeah,
and you can't forget the randomass naked bath scene of >> So
he's just doing like Naku. This is like a Naku video.
Is it [laughter] >> Meumi at the end of this episode? >> It's
like I don't know. There's like some combination of of like anime
viewers, but anime viewers who will openly like all of the anime
they look at in a public space. It's like never a good combination
of things. It's like always bad. It's all it never turns out
well. Like why would >> you just if you watch anime, you
don't talk about this stuff. You don't if you don't it constantly.
You might be okay, but my god, if you constantly like you constantly
make it, it's not good. It's never good. >> You as an author
write in a scene of a 12-year-old doing quite >> He's saying
it's bad though. >> Okay. episode. Like, why would you
as an author write in a scene of a 12-year-old doing quite literally
anything else when you can write in them taking a nice warm wash?
Very normal behavior. And in episode 6, when Megumi comes over
to continue the Sigma grind set of Sigiri, she just takes off
her panties just straight up. But by far the worst of the worst
is absolutely held for the last episodes even though they have
full beach trip. Is he like saying it's bad or is he doing is
he saying it's bad or is he doing the noaku thing where he's
like h look how outrageous this is and not really making a commentary.
>> Classic anime trope episodes where yeah you get the
classic lotion on back bath scenes the whole nine. But in episode
12, to get even more research, Sigiri forces Elf and Muramasa
to play a fun, wholesome game of Twister in some very >> Okay,
I'm coming in halfway through. >> Very safe for work bikinis
to get the most pristine inspiration for her artwork. Like, man,
I I just can't I can't imagine the [__] who would
write this. And later on, Sigiri gets inspired to draw a manga
for some reason. Don't don't ask the context. I don't even want
to explain. But she goes on to draw a few scenes. And of course,
as you do, have your friends review it. And apparently, she draws
the dick weird or wrong. And Masamune comments that it's not
the way it's supposed to look, causing them to go on an expedition
to find out what a dick looks like. Yeah, they haven't got any
older in case you were wondering. I was really hoping. And eventually,
the girls start stripping Masamune to see what his dick looks
I need a shower after this. And just like that, the anime ends.
So, in conclusion, Aramanga Sensei is an anime with some of the
biggest potential wasted on absolutely the dumbest [__]
in the world with unique and captivating plot lines to wholesome
encounters throughout the whole story. This could have been a
9 out of 10 anime easily for me. If you strip away all the sus
with the sibling romance and just pointless fanervice scenes,
like come on, bro. So disappointed. But yeah, see you guys next
time. Okay, so the final conclusion doesn't say anything about
the age of the people. It sounds like he was saying it during
I'd have to go watch the whole thing. And I'll be honest, I don't
give a [__] So, go ahead and click back on this video.
This guy summing it up more >> beforehand. Trigger warning
uh that anime uh honestly if he's just saying it's bad, it's
like probably hard to criticize unless there's a large pattern
of behavior, right? So, I'm guessing there is just a large pattern
of behavior like all the things we're about to see here with
the he liked on Twitter, just straight autism and like borderline
child like depiction in a weird
manner is present in this part of the video. So, I don't know,
man. Kind of weird. But Lyric's Twitter likes are a genuine degenerate
cesspool. Like, it's in Yeah, that's what I figured. >> That's
like what I figured was it was going to go to this stuff. Why
did Larry quit the anime reviews for music? If he stuck with
anime, no one would care. He likes Well, the issue is he went
to commentary in the middle of those two things. Why'd he go
to the most critical space on Earth
while doing this stuff first and then he tried to go to a non-critical?
It It's a little weird to me how this is not being called out
by somebody else yet because it is beyond weird. It's just like
kind of sick even. Like I look at this and I get uncomfortable
as this isn't me trying to like moral grandstand or whatever
or anything like that, but this is the same guy that calls out
other people and calls them gay cringe losers. And meanwhile,
he's liking cute anime cat girls online. [laughter] I mean, saying
it just seems so unreal, but I'm not lying. Thing is, too, is
like from these pictures, these girls, >> it's a good thing
that Elon has now hidden likes. It's not really. It was a very
good source of, you know,
very good source of content. >> Look very young and it
is kind of sus. But I don't think lyrics is like a or any of
that [__] I don't want you guys to go out there.
I mean, like if that's what you think, that's what you think,
but that's not what I think. And I'm just saying this because
like I'm not trying to say, oh, Larry exposed as a like this
is simply just calling him cringe and gay and he has no place
to talk like whenever he's talking [__] about all
these people. Don't get me wrong, the people he talks about are
too, but it just seems so weird whenever he's the one saying
it. You know what I mean? Like, you go on his Twitter likes and
there are hundreds of likes of little anime girls that look like
they're actually six years old, girls with cat ears,
like girls that have like just barely covering in their ass and
like very
It's all weird anime
whenever you translate it cuz it's all in Japanese. Okay, that
one was pretty rough. Okay, like that one. Oh, so hold on. That
one is bad.
Not because it's but because it's like why are you just liking
I man?
I could see how someone could defend
I could see how you'd defend it, right? It's like oh well it's
not. But it's like dude, I don't know if somebody was going around
liking real life six-year-olds all the time. It would also be
extremely weird.
Whenever you translate some of this, it says like, "Oh, this
is so cute. Heart emoji or stuff like that." And on Valentine's
Day, Lex was just tweet he was liking all these tweets of anime
girls with like Valentine's Day hearts. Like, it's so weird.
At this point, I'm convinced L has a body pillow. Might be even
worse that it's not it's not great in any case. Okay. Right behind
his camera that's just filled with has no like sane mentally
well nuts, >> dude. body pillow right behind his camera
just filled with [laughter] >> parlo exposed. Little did
they realize,
little did they realize
come cuz no like sane mentally wellnuts
crave degenerate likes this [__] Like I swear to
God some people might say, "Oh, it's wholesome all this other
shit." But whenever you put it all together and this [__]
is not wholesome. It does not look wholesome at all. I'm going
to go out on a limb and say this guy likes 2D girls over 3D girls
cuz your 2D waifu can never reject you. lyrics when he makes
all these videos about women and how much he like hates women
and how stupid they are. And I'm not trying to say like, "Oh,
he's a misogynist or whatever." But he makes all these videos
on women. It just kind of gets you thinking, dude. Like, do you
secretly wish that these girls were like in anime whenever they're
like heroes or they're submissive and breedable as
like holy, dude. In between these like tweets of literal children
in anime costumes and just it's just weird. Okay, BUT IN BRO,
HOW LONG IS HE going to scroll for? I feel like he's gone one
day.
February 14th. He gets to like February 12th. Dude,
dude, how long can he scroll L's likes? Your 2D waifu can never
reject you. Lyrics. I mean, he makes all these videos about women
and how much, >> bro. That was two days of likes that he
just scrolled. That's insane. >> He like hates women and
how stupid they are. And I'm not trying to say like, oh, he's
a misogynist or whatever, but he makes all these videos on women.
It just kind of gets you. Lar didn't realize Twitter likes were
public.
How you thinking, dude? Like, do you secretly wish that these
girls were like in anime whenever they're like heroes or they're
submissive and breedable as
like holy, dude. In between these like tweets of literal children
in anime costumes and just it's just weird. Okay, but in between
that is like other people like Auggie calling somebody cringe.
It's like holy, dude. You have any self-awareness whatsoever?
has all these videos calling other people pathetic losers when
I think the only pathetic loser in this equation is you lyrics.
Or maybe you're with them, dude. It's your Mochu Mochu body pillow
and go get in line, dude. That's where you belong is with the
pathetic losers in that line. If you guys don't believe me about
3D women, how much he literally just doesn't want to them, dude.
He is so done with real life girls, man. He can never even touch
a in real life, dude.
you know, we're going to be honest. There's like she did cheat
on Turkey to she I mean, I I feel like you can call a cheater,
right? I think that's fair. I think that's fair. >> Like
this basically star named uh Lauren Alexis or some I think that's
it. And basically he made a video on her like why would anybody
you have to be so down bad to off to this like you 12-year-old
and horny degenerate men are off to this >> Oh we're straight
in with the throw it back as I was doing a Tik Tok dance. Okay
so I still can't really do this but I know people on Tik Tok
kind of like
lift their leg up leg up. So they're
Lar was just like man I wonder if I could spin a wheel like this.
I I actually I can't even I can't even record this video. I can't
record this. This This isn't real. This isn't real life. How
could you be this horny? How could you be this horny, dude? Like,
godamn. I've had my moments. Everybody's had their moments. I'm
an 18-year-old boy. But dude, to sit through this, to sit through
this and say some >> I'm sorry. If you're an 18-year-old
guy and you see like nothing going on there, you might just be
like, I'm starting to doubt that he's Is he Turkey Tom's girlfriend
or is he just getting groomed? Which one is it? Cuz like, dude,
like, god damn, I've had my moments. Everybody's had their moments.
Is the fanboy, dude? Yes, it is. But dude, to sit through this,
to sit through this and to somehow get any
you're horrible. You're down into the six feet. >> I mean,
you're down bad, but like that person's attract. I don't know
what he's talking about. >> You're chilling with the gravestones
at that point, buddy. You're not There's no coming back for you
if you to this. This is abominable. I I actually I can't even
I can't even record this video. I can't record this. [__]
this. [__] this. >> This is so insanely performative.
This is like
This is ludicrously performative. It's not even believable.
It's like actually
I mean this would this put me off of a creator entirely. It's
just so weird to to go and do this whole meme like this. This
isn't real >> in like a meant to be serious way. Like he's
trying to be serious. >> This isn't real life. How could
you be this horn? >> Why Why would Grimsy do this to him?
Why would Grimsy do this? Why would Grimsy throw this this picture
up?
This soed up. How could you be this horny, dude? Like, godamn.
I've had my moments. Everybody's had their moments. I'm an 18-year-old
boy. But, dude, to sit through this to sit through this and to
somehow get any satisfaction.
This is when the commentary meta was raging at Twitch thoughts.
Okay, >> you're well. You're down into the >> Wait,
hold on. >> I would get any satisfaction.
>> You're up again. New video on the lyrics versus Stardust
debate. It's pretty funny. Link in the replies. Bunk is based,
bro. These guys these guys like made videos of horrible. You're
down in >> and to bring this in. He's very food
>> I mean, I don't know if I'd say that, but we'll see.
Oh, I got the Omega video here in just a second. Actually, Lyrics
never ever said any of this. Hold on. All girls should be small,
short, feminine, submissive, cute, and nice. If not, you
innocence is attractive. Don't want a girl who already knows
how to suck. To be honest, that's unappealing to me. Yeah, there's
a lot of flags here. There's a lot of flags here. Okay. A lot
of a lot of flags.
Colors not really to be debated. Just a lot of flags. Okay. Into
the six feet under. You're chilling with the gravestones at that
point, buddy. You're not. There's no coming back for you if you
it to this. This is a no. Twitter likes Twitter likes are no
longer public. They were public. They are no longer abominable.
I mean, look at the pure disgust on Lary's face. 3D woman with
a fat ass. What the dude? I only it to 2D women online, okay?
And they have to be in the anime style, the anime format, dude.
And their ass has to be hidden, bro. You know, I it to the real
man, okay? This is what real men. Like seriously, could you even
imagine off to a girl with a fat ass that actually shows it off
and actually is a star? Imagine that, dude. Imagine not off to
sketches on a screen, dude. And a fake anime girl. I mean, dude,
Lauren Alexis is never going to you, dude. My wife, my waifu,
okay, my body pillow waifu. I have with it every single night.
She's my queen. But this an actual girl, what the [__]
I don't know,
man. It seems really gay and the >> the voice is exact
for like the leafy
>> I hear lyrics. >> You'd think he'd want a little
>> talk the more I hate this kid. If you see him he's the
kind of guy that always calls everybody else sensitive and likes
to talk all this about everybody else. You know he I he like
referred to me as a spur because me and Toxic Distress found
his second channel and I like jokingly said to toxic. I'm like
dude you think Lary is a virgin? So Toxic Distress asked him
and then Lary was like, "Lo, you're not you're joking, right?"
And and then Toxic was like, "No." He flipped out on Toxic was
like, "Grim's a spur." All this other you're sp. And uh he essentially
thought that like Toxic was trying to bait him into like being
a
I'll be honest. I feel like these are all like 16 to 18 year
olds and I it's like suddenly just become like not very interested.
Like they're all so young. They're having like these fights.
Uh, actually, he was he called me a spur and that's terrible.
Okay. Or some [__] I mean, actually
high schoolers argue about their drama as behavior. But like,
this is the same guy that goes on Twitter every day and he's
like, "You're a brain rot. YOU'RE BRAIN DEAD, DUDE. SHUT THE
UP. YOU'RE actually like, holy, dude. Calm down. Like, your body
pillow is just next to you, dude. Going and come back. Maybe
you'll be a little less irritated. Like, holy [__]
It's just online. Like always his advice for people flipping
it out about like and being sensitive online is it's literally
just the internet. Dude, get used to it, bro. If you want to
come in here in the hardcore game where I'm at, just get used
to it. I don't think he's going to react very well to this video
because considering the mere fact or question of me asking if
he's a virgin apparently makes me a spur. I wonder what this
is going to do. And regarding the virgin argument, I'm 900% sure
that I know the answer now. Yes, Larry is absolutely a virgin,
dude. There's no way that anybody who has actually touched a
woman in their entire life likes this [__] on Twitter.
The only way Larry lost his virginity is if he did it with his
body pillow and that's it. And honestly, it's fine, dude. If
you want to go off and like watch anime cartoons and be a little
[__] all day and be cringe as by all means, dude.
Go ahead. But don't sit there and call everybody else, "Oh, you're
gay. You're a loser. You're cringe." Cuz lyrics, look in the
mirror. You're a kid that goes on Twitter and specifically likes
anime cat girls for hours at a time per day. What the [__]
are you? So yeah, I've had a couple of interactions with lyrics
and not really any of them have been good. I talked to him one
time after he dropped a video about Jaden and he seemed pretty
cool then. Um and then he started getting getting clout, you
know, talk to from all these bigger guys and then uh yeah, I
I guess he kind of forgot about me. And then whenever uh we asked
if he was a virgin, he said, "I thought that grimsy guy was cool,
but he's really just a spur and he's a brain rot." It's insane,
man. If it makes me brain rot to have a girlfriend and have on
a consistent basis, then I guess I'm my brain is completely rotted
out, dude. Because I guess to not be brain rot, to not be a spur,
to not be gay. >> Uh between like guys like this and guys
like Fuentes, I just choose Fuentes. Okay. Like I'm sorry.
Like I people thinking like having is like changes something
in your life is so stupid. It's such a just gives me like a migraine
listening to people go through this. Especially somebody whoever
whoever however old this person is. I just get like a migraine
when I hear
cringe. You have to your to anime girls online. [laughter] Your
interaction with women consists of you looking at pretty pictures
of anime cat girls [laughter] on Twitter. You know this guy?
This guy right here. So gay, dude. He's so cringe and gay. >> Yo,
bro, where's that at? Basically, what I'm trying to say is Lyrics,
my fellow commentator, my Twitter rival, my most hated enemy,
my what I'm trying to say here is that you're really gay. And
um at the end of the day, you know, I don't have a problem if
you do this in private, but why have it on your Twitter likes?
And also on top of that, why do these girls look like they're
15? Like, are you on some high? Okay. All right. I'm I'm done
with this guy. that went from like funny and cool to awful. As
soon as that guy involved himself, that video went from like
funny to just terrible. Like the second he was like, "Oh, and
also Lyric said this about me." It immediately like nosedived
into the ground.
Okay. Lyrics lost lyrics. Funny moments on Omega. Apparently,
this is where the possibly past comes from. >> I mean,
>> hey, do you want to hear my friend sing? >> You
look like a goth girl. >> Me? I am not. No, I'm very far
from goth. She's the goth girl. >> Let's see the goth girl.
Let's see him. Let's see him. >> Nope. Nope. Nope. >> Does
she got big? Let's see him. >> Let's see him. >> Okay.
Wait. Do I hear a sing? >> Uh, I just >> I kind of
just want to see her. I'm not going to lie.
>> [__] you. >> Are you good?
>> [__] you AND YOUR MOTHER THAT ME WANT HER
BACK. >> HEY, my name is Hanito and I like the
>> You've never kissed a girl, have you? Who?
Boo. >> Oh [__] it's a gay kid.
Oh, Larry's talked to this gay kid. I immediately recognized
that gay kid.
>> What's wrong, kid?
>> I just got bullied for being gay. >> Oh, yeah.
What's about to happen again?
>> It's that kid, right? I'm pretty I'm pretty confident
that's the same kid. Ah, suck my >> I will. No homo. Uh-huh.
Quiet now, aren't you? [laughter]
>> Interesting. We got a wild furry on the
>> Can I smile? Anime [__] in the back. >> You
want to see my clock? You want to see? [clears throat] You want
to see it?
>> Are you a woman?
>> Oh, so you you clean dishes like and
examine this, right?
another black screen. How many black screens? How I'm sick and
tired of seeing black. Hello, dude. I mean black screens. I black
getting tonight. What's >> Why don't you show your face?
>> Cuz I don't want to. >> Are you ugly?
>> I just don't want to. >> Is that wild Latina?
>> Why not? How old are you?
>> Oh no. Don't do the Don't do the zera bit. Not good.
>> My favorite. >> What's up, beautiful? >> That's
like Is that all Omega and Monkey content is? Is just the zerka
bit over and over again?
We're like 14, actually. Oh, that's not a problem for me. It's
like just that joke again and again and again and again and again
and again.
>> Oh my god.
>> How old are you?
>> I'm 15.
>> What's up, cutie?
>> How old are you?
>> Oh, you're hot. >> EDP transitions. Funny. Whoa.
Whoa. Whoa. How old are you? >> I'm 16.
Well, I was actually coming out here to pick up a cupcake. Okay.